[Applause]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you've watched two
or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
while you're at it guys we have just
started we've just launched a clips
channel and thanks to you guys we're
already at almost 3k in like a week
which is nuts um so go subscribe to the
clips channel that way if you guys you
know want just simple short clips then
you can go subscribe to that on top of
that we have a members only chat today
we have three tiers we have a five
dollar tier a ten dollar tier oh we know
we have four tiers we entered a fourth
tier you can also do a for the fourth
tier which you get to do a one-on-one
call with me every month so if you want
to do that sign up for our memberships
um we also are doing a members only live
stream that's next wednesday
my instagram is just dot pearly things
and sign up for our memberships because
it's going to help us we are moving into
a bigger studio this um probably the
next like month or so so if you guys
want to see us do different types of
content outside of just this on separate
channels we want to take some of the
show guests bring them back do like
smash your past dating shows like all
different types of content that would
just be a lot of fun but we need a
bigger studio in order to do it so the
memberships are really important because
it gives us a consistent form of income
and lastly we have a member of the week
which is chris
chris has been donating all week and we
really appreciate it and every week we
are going to do a member of the week so
if you want to be a member of the week
sign up for our memberships so today we
have a lovely panel so why don't we go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and a fun fact
starting with kit
so hi my name is kit i am 28 years old
i'm single and fun fact is
uh i was
born with my tongue
tied to my gums and i had to have
surgery to get it sword
okay
hi uh my name is rotendo oru um
i'm 27 years old and fun fact
i don't know i like to be a contrarian
just for the sake of it that's about it
okay
um my name is sheena i'm 27 years old
and i'm single
fun fact i'm allergic to cats and dogs i
don't know if that's fun but
okay i'm montana um i'm 28 years old and
i'm immuno in a relationship um fun fact
um
i would say
i won netball player of the year in year
9.
okay okay athlete
my name is param also known as banksy
style online um i'm older than everyone
here and no one needs to know how old
exactly
uh
and
fun fact i worked
as the it manager for an adult
entertainment or adult
movie production newspaper magazine
company
back in the day
my name's samuel i'm 29 years old i am
taken
and fun fact about me is
um i used to be on a radio show with my
friend about four years ago
so
today's topic is what does your
submission cost
so out of curiosity i was doing a little
research for this show and i wanted to
know what
was the history of like did women do
dowries like what was that like in
england because i know it might have
been a little different than the us
so this is what i found due to the
importance of land daughters posed a
large problem for landowning families
other than widows not many women owned
land and many daughters certainly did
not receive any so they did not carry an
estate with them upon marriage it was
important for families to maintain
social status which meant a daughter was
never married to someone of lower
standing
mothers and fathers spent much time
searching for the best possible spouse
for their child in order to benefit the
family as as a result families typically
placed a dowry on their daughter which
consisted of a large sum of money
these marriage negotiations were some of
the most demanding strains on the mother
and the father due to a family's
heritage and legacy being at stake this
came to this came along another problem
the idea of individualism reason and
romantic sensibility began growing
rapidly in the early part of the century
leading to daughters wanting to choose
their own husbands for poor families not
nearly as much was at stake when
marrying thus the pr thus relieving
pressure it was important to transfer
poverty to one to one another or any
kind of societal status as a result of
marriage so men and women women were
free to choose who they wanted and the
reason i was looking at this is because
i always hear the phrase like
he has to make a certain amount of money
for me to submit and i was just curious
if there was any like his history behind
it
so i have a question for the ladies
what
does a man have to make to marry you
what does er no what does sorry let me
rephrase it what does your submission
cost um
and actually let me start sorry sorry
would you would you submit to a man if
so what does your submission cost
there's a better way to phrase it um
for me i would say it doesn't
it doesn't speak to the mic
it doesn't cost
um
a particular amount he doesn't have to
make a particular amount i just think
what's important is that he's working
and for me i have a child as well so
for me
i mean
not initially i mean initially he
wouldn't necessarily be involved with my
son and everything but just to see that
he's able to have a good relationship
with children
and things of that nature that is
important to me because someone anyone
that i'm going to be with well
that i'm with
um it's important that they have
a relationship with my child
so
as long as you're working it doesn't
cost so you have to if he's making 15
000 pounds a year
okay um in the current climate i don't
think it's you would submit he can make
all the decisions in the household so
like at some point there's a number
right we're not we're not dating
homeless men yeah
yeah at least i'm not i mean yeah i
don't know but
but
so where about what about 25 000 that's
the
average medium income
is this 500 is this
it says the median average salaries for
work all workers in the uk is 25 000
pounds
what okay what you can be honest what
job title okay if okay
for me
it's a no it's a no
that wouldn't sustain
much and
what job would you be having at
i'm 28 so anyone
that i would be with has to be around my
age or higher so what job are you
working that you're only receiving a
salary of 25 grand that's not going to
cut it so no no higher than
35
yeah that that would do 30 so your
submission cost your submission costs
roughly 35. around yeah roughly okay
okay i think i would have to agree as
well because
in terms of like you were talking about
your daughter i have a sister who's got
autism
yeah yeah
i have a sister that's got autism so
there's a lot of difficulties with that
and i have health issues myself so it's
like
you know like i would want someone more
about you know who could actually deal
with those things and be there in those
difficult times because i know not a lot
of people
will be willing to
be part of that so
but in terms of your question
it would have to be that
plus what you just said which would be
35 well i mean if he's if he's barely
working you know he'd have a lot of time
to support you
you know like emotionally
he would be there
he would be there
if anything like like that's better for
you right
now
so roughly 35 yeah okay and and with
that you would let him make all the
decisions in the household
like financially all your money's his
money he makes all the decisions
my money won't be his money
well that's that's you don't think
that's part of submission no no it's
relinquishing trouble
i think actually i mean i think it
depends on the man himself i don't think
every man wants to be in control of
every penny that comes into the
household
but
yeah you can make majority of the
decisions but
i think
well yeah i think we can move but
actually i'm going to do the definition
of submission just so i probably should
have started with that the action of
accepting or yielding to a superior
force or to the will or authority of
another person
so like it would be what he says goes
essentially i
um 35 000 a year
everything i know i don't i don't i
don't think any i don't think most men
want to control everything though what i
don't think most men want to control
everything you're also not answering the
question
so so i'm saying like submission is
relinquishing control and that's part of
feminism
yes that's that's
it's
submission
if you're okay so if you work for a boss
right like you they get to they say what
you do yeah they say how much you're
paid yeah so that that's submission you
submit to your boss the person has
authority over you yeah and so you can
pick which boss you want to work for
yeah but at the end of the day
you're relinquishing control that's part
of submission
for me it depends with the situation if
you're earning 35
preferably if you're a student like i
don't know your medical student or a
peer or something then that makes sense
during the dating phase but if i know
okay fine by the time we get married or
while you're studying then you're
earning more fine
but it's not really financial the other
like intangible things that i would
be looking at for me to submit to you
that's about it
so i'm not talking about because that's
a lot of times like the mating strategy
girls do we'll get him young and we'll
try to build him up no no this is an
average guy
no this is this is this is this is he's
earning today this is what he's going to
earn tomorrow
forever because most those people are
average you have to be tactful though
that's right you have to be attacked for
well i mean i think you guys are
misreading this uh you you hung up on
the 35 35 was like the the next level up
from the 25. what i think pearl is
trying to ask is what would be the
amount the monetary amount that he could
earn that you would be like i'm talking
when when i mean i don't know if that's
what you mean but when i'm talking
submission i'm talking middle east and
submission
he is literally you come home she's
there with the slippers in her hand and
and she's there yeah dinner is on the
table hello sir how are you my darling
so he says he says quit your job you say
one yes okay no questions yeah yeah yeah
okay
it has to be a lot higher than that just
like maybe over 50
just then
over so over 50.
but it depends with your age
as well
no no no remember he's not this isn't
build a man
no no no no
no no no this is what he earns today
this is what he's gonna earn tomorrow i
think 50 is like a reasonable number
okay 50 000 pounds yeah i think i would
say 50 then yeah yeah
if you're going complete
okay submission
um i would say like 70
and beyond 70 000 pounds that would be
enough to
withhold
the life that means and and do you guys
genuinely think you could at that
relinquish all control
yeah i mean if i'm earning 50 years
earning 50 we're earning 100k yeah you
could live comfortably okay so yeah
sorry
do you think at that at 50 you could
relinquish all control your money is his
money do you think that's possible for
you
his money's all money my money is hit
our money yes yeah yeah okay but he
makes the decisions on it that's fine
yeah okay okay cool
yeah
i don't know i don't know i'm very
the thing is like i'm not sure if i want
to get married so
it's a different topic in itself but if
we're talking hypothetically if it was
like
you know this is a decision you have to
make
yeah i'll probably have to go higher
okay
100 60
70. no i just want to know what the
number is yeah maybe 17. for me to like
completely
because otherwise yeah i i don't think i
could okay so that's the starting yeah
okay so i have a question for the men do
you think it's fair for women to require
a certain income for them to come
do you think it's fair for women to
require a certain income for them to
submit
it's not really about fairness it's just
that some
way it is it is an exchange of security
and commodity for love and and child um
i mean it is kind of i don't want to
make it out to be like i mean i know
disney wants to make you believe that
you know love and all that starry-eyed
stuff can happen but in reality most
people are looking at you know what am i
giving up going into this and what am i
getting in return right that's why i
brought up the dowry earlier it's
because there is some history that that
does correlate a bit with you have to
have something in order to get get a
girl
so
so what do you what do you think i would
say it's okay for her to have that
standard so long as she understands
that the man is going to have standards
for her
so the more you ask from a man the more
the higher standards he's going to have
for you
so one thing that we obviously see all
the time is
the more a woman
requires a man to make
a lot of the time the more attractive
she has to be and maintain for him
so if you think that correlation if you
think okay well okay well the guy who i
would accept and submit to
right has to be making 100k
which is in the top
10
of earners
you better make sure you're on the top
10 of the most attractive women
consistently facts
i mean sorry oh me oh yeah um
i would say
i don't i don't think it's fair that we
put a monetary amount on things in terms
of submission i think a woman should
submit to the man regardless of how much
he earned
in that sense but at the same time we
have to just like um banks he said we
have to base
it on reality and what reality of life
is you have to make money to be able to
submit if you want your missus to stay
at home and do nothing there has to be
enough money coming in for her to be
able to do that and for you to be able
to live that life of coming home when
your slippers are ready your dinner's
all warm and everything's all all nice
and cozy for you you have to make enough
money for that to happen and that's just
the reality but i was gonna say i was
gonna say on that i think
um if a woman is going to be the kind of
woman that she submits in a relationship
you submit to the man you choose
so there's no kind of okay this is who i
choose but he actually doesn't make
enough so i'm not going to submit it's
not that if he doesn't make enough for
you if that's the standard of yours then
that's not the man you choose
but if you choose him
right then you are inadvertently saying
i submit myself to you if that's the
kind of woman you're gonna be it's the
same way like we don't say to guys ah
well how attractive does a girl have to
be for you to protect her
do you know what i mean don't go okay
well she's my girlfriend she's not that
attractive
no one does that like if a man chooses a
woman that's the woman he's chosen to
serve in the way that a man knows how to
serve well it's kind of funny because i
always hear girls say broke men
shouldn't have an opinion but we don't
guys don't say fat chicks shouldn't have
an opinion
speak your truth i think your truth yeah
everyone can have an opinion but that
doesn't mean people listen to you it's
as simple as that yeah that doesn't mean
how valued your opinion is
right that's it that's it what ish do
you want you think it's fair
uh do i think we'll sorry yeah we'll use
the camera we got you come on come on
i just saved for the audience it is when
the spanking you pair trainers right now
[Laughter]
what are you what do you think um what
do i think about do you think it's fair
that that men have to have a certain
amount of money
i don't really think about fairness i
think the world works the way it works
if you earn enough money
there are certain things that you have
access to are
or are privileged to and so um
you find that the more you earn
the better you get
the more attractive women you're able to
attain and so
it's just the rules of nature
the game is the game that's how i just
learn to play it okay so question for
the women what percent of men do you
think make 70 000 pounds a year or more
in the uk
20
15
maybe
what do you think
um 15
okay
[Laughter]
so according this
i think i'm reading it right it says 60
000 pounds is in the 90th percentile
no it's not i don't i don't know if i'm
reading this right but i think this is
what it says the thing is uh it all
depends if you're looking at london if
you're looking at youtube
from personality
oh that's probably why let me let me
break it down by london yeah because
london it has a as a higher
much higher view
than anywhere else in the country
uh so yeah income let me just look it up
real quick london income breakdown
even if we double it that's still
can answer a question for the ladies
yeah you know when you said about um
you know you said about okay this is how
much um
you know a man would have to make for
you to submit to him and obviously you
don't have to share that this
information but
what were were your answers relative to
how much you earn
yeah technically yeah
okay
so if you earn less the threshold might
be lower and if you're more the
threshold would probably be higher
you see the trick
the trick in this in this situation what
i find is that
even though you say um you you're happy
with a man who earns 50 60 000 pounds
and if that is relative to what you earn
what you're not taking into account is a
lot of men can or want to say that once
my you know once i get married i don't
want my woman to work at all so actually
it's not relative to what you earn
because he may not want you to work at
all so what you earn is zero no no but i
was asking the question of
for them yeah what their preference was
as to who they would submit to was it in
relation to it in relation to how much
they are
okay it actually
half a million a year you would still
say 70k
oh well no no no
no
yeah
yeah it's in relation to that it's
relative to what you were earning
because if you can make 100 000 pounds a
year then why would you you wouldn't you
wouldn't submit to a man that makes 50.
well no i wouldn't but i thought you
meant as in was i considering the amount
that i earned comparing it to the amount
that i would submit to
no that's what i've witnessed
yes
because i wasn't comparing the amount
that i earned to the amount that i'd
submit to but because because i guess
let's let's even ish is gonna look up
like what the actual percentages of men
that make over a certain amount but so
do you think
do you think you're in the top twenty
percent of females
to get that
top 20 innocent one financially no just
like in what men value which is like
femininity beauty it starts with looks
femininity beauty do you think you're in
the top 20 of females no
so then if if
i then you probably would be dating a
gut be dating a guy that makes less
do you think it'd be a problem if you
couldn't submit to a guy that dates less
do you think that would cause issues in
a relationship
it would yeah i'm just talking from
experience from what i've observed from
other people's marriages
yeah yeah what do you think
yeah i think it most likely would
yeah
it would yeah
um
so what's the question
so
since
let's say
20 of men make over that yeah
um which is just gonna fact check cuz i
wasn't sure but
do you think you're in the top 20 of
females
i'd like to believe so but um
i don't know why not i think so maybe
top 20 of females
i mean would it help if you had some
females that are in the top 20 that you
could give examples so that they can
okay okay okay so um i mean kevin
samuels always says beyonce is an eight
okay so do you think you're as pretty as
beyonce no
or kelly i don't really think beyonce is
that pretty in all honesty or rihanna so
um
i think rihanna's prettier yeah um
yeah i mean but would you say you're in
that if i had enough money as rihanna
yeah i think i could be
because she they all have money so money
makes you look better like if they were
normal people no
it starts with it starts yeah they're
very like big ladies with money they're
there
oprah for example i think money helps
optimize what's there yeah yeah that's
what i mean yeah that's right
but i was going to say like
is it being fit and it's outfit feminine
and friendly yeah i have all that but
i'm not fit yet i'm working towards it
and and it goes by facial symmetry so
the way i look at it is like
most people are average right so i do
four like and i kind of take it i'm
gonna give credit cause i know in the
comments they'll be like credit kevin
samuels yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay
i know i know i know i always think of
like eight is the prettiest girl in a
small town nine means you make it to
hollywood based on your looks 10 is damn
near perfect so nines and tens they'll
make it to hollywood eight's the
prettiest girl in a small town i don't
really give out like sevens because you
have to pick are you are you beautiful
gorgeous are you cute
and and so most people are four fives
and sixes are pretty you're cute
yeah i'm average i think
okay yeah i definitely say i'm like an
average four maybe or something yeah
okay
um
that's that's humble like that's i get
credit just facts i mean a lot of girls
a lot of girls come on and say 10 so
go ahead you know i wouldn't say i'm a
10 but i don't necessarily think i'm
average maybe just a bit
beyond that like like six yeah okay okay
six
but like i this is just a common problem
that i see in relationships is like
as
average girls we want above average guys
and then we can't submit to the guys
that are at our level
um
he just jumped
yeah these are because like average is
35 000 that's the average income in
london
or it might be 45. but we said up to 70
we said up to 70 to fully commit which
is i'm not knocking you forward i think
a lot of people would say the same
things
i guess when you say fully commit for us
it's submit yeah submit is like you've
given
all yourself away yeah so it's like it's
i guess it's a hard thing to grasp
because i guess we live in an
environment where that's not taught or
not really yeah yeah
well it's like there can't be two there
can't be two ceos in a house someone has
to lead yeah have you ever been in a
relationship where you had felt like you
had to lead yeah yeah yeah and i had to
end those like take any you take
initiative for goodness sake yeah what
are you yeah same it just it just feels
like you're the man yeah yeah and very
uncomfortable yeah it does not feel you
don't feel safe yeah
yeah
oh the same yeah
and i'm curious from the guys have you
ever had experiences where the women
like tried to lead
in this country yeah
yeah i mean um it's
you get you got a lot of women who have
a very strong male energy and they want
to lead even in dancing yeah we're doing
salsa i'm like love
i'm i have to do this
hold on
and they're like trying to make moves
i'm like no this and that this was a
reflection of the relationship where
they were constantly i'm like look i'll
make this decision i'll make this call
how about next time you make the call
and then and so on we're talking small
things like one time
we went into a bar and um
i made the decision of the drinks well i
mean i didn't make the decision i'm like
you're drinking this i said this is a
really nice drink
i drink it all the time would you like
to try it and she liked that but
then again other times it was always
like a little bit of pushback on on
things that i said look i know what well
what i'm doing here it's okay i got this
but it was a constant
you know push and pull and that's i
think it is because of women have very
strong you know some women have very
strong male energy
with the submission thing like the
intangible things that i look for is can
you take initiative for me i find it
hard to find a guy who wants to take
initiative you asked me out and then you
asked me to plan the date like no [ __ ]
no no bye
i'm not doing that
like i've dealt a couple of um girls who
maybe you know maybe try to take leading
certain things or whatever
and it's weird and this is some game for
the guys
um i said to one of my friends he was
considering buying his first place with
his girlfriend i said don't do it it was
like your first place as a man should be
yours and i'll give you this story as to
why
there was a girl who was dating at one
point where
she stayed with me for like a couple of
weeks and i owned my own home and stuff
um and
when she was staying she was trying to
make certain decisions for the household
and then it was like we went away on
holiday and stuff and we drove you know
in my car and everything
and there was certain decisions she was
trying to make and i was like you know
i'm a i'm a nice guy like i'm reasonable
do you know what i mean but then it did
get to a point where i had to be like
you're at my house
this is my house everything i've sorted
for us i've done for us
right so if i'm not okay with something
it's not happening
i wouldn't be able to do that
if there was
co-ownership
and it's not about necessarily having
control but i think as as a man part of
the when we say authority
it's almost like
you almost have to have that authority
on paper because you don't want to have
to play that card
if someone's trying to violate you
but you can play it if you need to does
that make sense so it's one of those
things where it's like
that's the only time where
i realized that
if i wasn't in that position
then there could have been even more of
a clash but it was like you know i was
like look but audrey swear like this is
my place like
kind of things was she doing she wanted
to like move some furniture around she
wanted to like i'm thinking you've been
here a week
at home i know something like when we
traveled she was like you know saying
she was saying stuff about
how
uh
something about how oh she was like
wanting to cook and stuff and she was
sending out that i didn't offer and the
reason i didn't offer because i had a
session with a client
and she was saying ah you've not helped
in this i was like i'm sorry who got us
here who
booked the hotel who did this this this
and this
and like when it's logistically true
like you can't argue with that so i
think um
that's the only time
where maybe she was somebody who was
used to being a masculine trying to lead
and she tried to lead in that sense
and that was
that was the only that was the only
efficient way i think a man maybe can
kind of reestablish him himself in that
position if that's where he wants to be
i don't know without example i would say
like i don't know from the
stuff i've heard from like new couples
um before they move in together into
their new home is before you move in you
have a discussion and negotiate the
house household things
certain rules boundaries things like
that so that you avoid
that sort of thing
she was staying with me oh okay that's
what i'm trying to say like okay
if she was moving in i think it would be
a little bit different because i'd be
like okay this is this is your home too
so like let's try and decide together
right but she was just staying with me
for a few weeks okay she wasn't moving
in okay and i was like
you're trying to this is
um can i leave my toiletries here
no and she was like oh please i was like
no
she was like what i just don't want you
to and she was like oh i'll cry i was
like you can grow up
wow that's cool that's cool
i had a russian girlfriend and
literally from the second or third day
when i took her well it wasn't even um
the first date we went around her place
and it was all good but the second date
the first date sorry she went we walked
to my car to drive to the to the bar
that we were going to go to and she
started critiquing my car because it was
a two-seater convertible and she was
like this car's too small i need a
bigger car i was like this is the first
date then by the third date when we were
around my place she started critiquing
the decor
of my place i'm like this is the third
date at least give it a month before you
start changing my life
do you think women try to change men
yeah yeah
yeah constantly i think i think but it's
not always a bad thing that's that's
what i would do yeah it's not always a
perfect some things are good some things
yeah yeah i think there's a there's a
general paradox i think
women try and change men and men expect
women to never change
i think you guys are more realistic
about what you have
because of course you'd want like a
beyonce who is virgin and and and holy
and all that but you can't get that in
re
real life so just realistic okay she's
nice she's friendly she's pretty and
that's what you go for so with women
they're not very
realistic about what they want i think
there was like this
um feminist lady she did like a survey
apparently like women had like 385
problems with the men that they dated
whereas men had only like 15 to 18
issues with the women that they dated on
average that's hilarious yeah
so men i'm already okay i'm not gonna
get beyonce i'm just gonna get
karen or whatever
oh they'll be fine with that well it's
interesting because there's so many
girls let's say like six feet six
figures six inches yeah but there's not
men that say that are average saying i
deserve a victorious secret yeah because
you're realistic yeah they well i think
reality hits men harder than women where
women whenever men have a standard
they're tried they're they're shamed for
it so like if they say i want thin
chicks they'll say fat shaming they'll
say i don't want to date a girl that's
been ran through it's [ __ ] shaming
where women if we have a standard were
praised for it
yeah the thing is don't settle yeah
do you have their standards i've i hear
a lot in the mgtow communities they're
they're constantly going about oh this
woman is this and i'm like dude have you
looked in the mirror have you seen who
you are yeah there's that one you start
talking about all these
terrible women out there so sometimes
men do have their unex and sort of
outrageous
expectations um and i've seen that
especially as i said these mgtow types
who who or even the in-cells who think
that uh you know these women are just
terrible i'm like dude
you have to fix yourself and then you'll
be amazed how much can i be honest i
think i think especially like maybe in
cells and stuff i think the reason
they're criticizing is because they feel
that they've been criticized a lot and
they feel like they don't measure up so
because it's the same thing like the
same insta model that they're
criticizing if she knocked on their door
you know he's taking her in a heartbeat
second you know i mean so i think i
don't think it comes from necessarily
because they think they deserve that i
think it's more because
because they've given up on the date and
game they feel that you know if they're
five
five and they don't reach six foot or
six figures all this and because we hear
that a lot that criticism from
women a lot i think they're like okay
well
if i'm you're if i'm not you're going to
criticize me for not being perfect i'm
going to criticize you for not being
perfect well i think well i think a lot
of the problem too is like average women
are rejecting average men
and so it leaves men average men
frustrated because basically they'll let
the like a guy that's an eight nine or
ten will sleep with a four five or six
and so then that girl will think she's
on his level and then the average guy
has to deal with all the baggage at 30.
and so i think that's why they're
frustrated as they're like i'm sick of
the ran through 32 year olds yeah 33.
and now that that would have rejected me
at 22 but now they want me because all
the they call them chads right
all the chads like
rejected them so i understand where
they're coming from but
yeah i mean you know there's it goes
both ways i think the way you refer to
the opposite gender kind of says more
about you like if you're the one saying
men or trash men are trash it says more
about you same thing with guys that say
women are [ __ ] women or horrors it's
like the same yeah but it is true that
there is this this this phenomena of
women in their 20s they ride what they
call the carousel there's another term
to that as well but they basically go
through all the different guys in their
20s and then when they hit the wall in
their mid-30s or early 30s they look for
the
the two main groups that in the in the
pickup artistry sort of
game what they call the the the lover
and the and the provider
now i myself have always been in the
provider category because i've never had
like you know good looking features in
in that sense so i've always known where
i can where which pond i can fish in
uh but there is the you know the women
go through all the lovers all the
good-looking guys all the bad boys all
of that through their 20s and all the
providers are actually busy with their
head down in programming or getting a
job or doing whatever
and then suddenly in their 30s these
guys when they've reached a good level
of income and housing and
and sort of well to do
those same girls in the 20s who wouldn't
give them the time of day are knocking
on their door
and back in the day there were a lot of
men who would simp for that and they
were like okay fine i'll take you even
though they know she's been ran through
the whole neighborhood
but this day day and age through the
internet and through a lot of people
like him in samuels
and actually pearl you could say she
could be one of those influences um they
are now changing the game because a lot
of young men are now i mean i think
you've got the stats on how many of them
are virgins they don't actually they're
not engaging in the dating game anymore
because they're like
why should i build all this up make all
this money do all this hard work just to
throw it at the feet of some some
hooters girl who's who ran through
all the guys in the neighborhood in her
20s and now she's knocking on my door so
i'm curious for the girls do you know
what the wall is mm-hmm oh you do yeah
okay it's a very a red pill can you
google um ish rolo tomasi um the wall um
just in relation to um the stat you were
looking for yeah it's 70 so if people
earn over 70 000 it's five percent okay
so five percent
okay nationwide
that makes sense nationwide yeah
nationwide five percent yeah can you can
you yeah so i'm going to show you guys
the wall is basically like
so
when you you turn like 15 you start
getting attention from men right i don't
know when's the first time you remember
getting hit on how old were you i think
13 oh wow 13. you were i was kind of
ugly at 13.
i didn't like it
maybe like 11 or something okay jesus
yeah about 12 13. yeah so women are born
with value while men have to create
their value
so basically you're given in the sexual
they call it the sexual marketplace
which is basically just how much value
you have to the opposite like how many
people want to date you supply and
demand
and they have a chart they made for
women
here
um ish is going to look it up but i'm
just going to show them real quick sure
so this is like
women's peak agency
do you see that so that's at like 22
that's when women have the most value
and then it starts to decline until
that's
we're men it's like a little staggered
it's after
so basically when women have their peak
like the most value they bring to men
they give it to the top percentage of
men and then
then later when they're down here they
want the average guys yeah
um i've sent you the definition
instagram oh okay the definition of what
um of the wall oh okay perfect that's
even no i meant like could you show the
chart or show the child sorry sorry
sorry my bad my bad also really quick um
oh what's uh
how much would it take for man to mate
for you to submit
so i don't know the conversions here
so like
so like 10 000 pounds i think right now
is about 14 000
i think in the in the u.s the average
the average i'm just gonna use us
because i know what the average is there
it's like 45
i think 45 is fine it's like forty
five yeah yeah like forty yeah
you would submit to a man that makes
forty to forty five thousand dollars
yeah i mean it depends it depends what
his job is like because i can promise
you you probably make more than that
right now
yeah i do but i just i feel like it's
when you look at all the stats like
what's my other option
i don't mean as you say hypergamy uh
crossing up oh don't get me wrong like i
would prefer it but i don't
also it depends how you live like the
reason why i put at 50
there's a way i want to live when i'm
married
so
i can make it work
living comfortably
yeah like let's see
like i did a fireman says fireman
adverts salary is like 30k that's fine
yeah you would yeah no you don't believe
me
honestly i call cap on that
i just i just think that everybody
operates on a base level yeah
like you mentioned from where they are
and they're like if i can make this now
it's like it's like you know
if i don't know if if i if i if it was
the rules were reversed between men and
women and men would marry rich older
women well i'm not going to marry a
woman that makes
fraction more than i do
i think men are hypergamous in looks
yeah yeah but what i mean is i'm talking
if there's some weird upside down
bizarro world of role reversal you know
it's crazy no women are actually harsher
on looks than men are now
i believe that yeah yeah i think i think
i think men
the same way women want a man who's
their level and up in terms of economic
standing
men want a woman his level of
attractiveness or up
in terms of
that's not what i see because i see a
lot of like like
fat chicks with skinny dudes today i was
in bento center and i was asking i was
just asking my sister like how did that
happen i think this couple i think in
regards to that though like it's
different him wanting that and him being
able to get it
if he had the options on the table yeah
well that's what i'm saying but i think
men are still like pickier or women are
still pickier than men even when it
comes to looks i think so yeah yeah yeah
yeah so even though they're hyper
pergamos it's just like the way the
dating market is now yeah men take what
they can get
yeah
a lot of times
because you don't have that much option
so did you show them the chart um i
couldn't find it if you just google it
the climate images
um but the thing is i mean it was a it
was a gentleman i think on this show
before he says if you're in the desert
and you're starving you're gonna take
whatever food they put in front of you
yeah it doesn't matter if it's some
mashed up meat or bugs or whatever
because you're starving you're in the
desert um yeah and so in in a sense and
it's not for some men certainly it's a
sexual desert out there and they
literally are unable to
i mean i don't know why
it's it's fine whatever um
so question for the girls
if a guy was in the one percent or let's
let's you know let's do top five percent
so now
and he wants to date you
but you have to share him
no i even say on the first date like
just be honest about the type of
relationship you want if you want
polygamy good luck to you it's not for
me if you want polyamory good luck to
you it's not for me i don't get mad at
that so would you rather have a guy that
makes less money and is monogamous to
you yeah okay
so let's actually i'm gonna up it one
percent this guy's multi-millionaire
you get you get the lifestyle so you get
cars nice house
and it's just casual so when he cheats
it's just a side chick
like the thing is i get that yeah good
for him yeah but i wouldn't i wouldn't
you wouldn't do it no what it did
yeah okay what about just random sex um
i'd like to believe that i could but no
it wouldn't work no no because it
is it nelly
that's
yeah so i don't know i feel like his
wife knew from the job yeah about the
situation
but then obviously like finding out how
he does his dirt like without a condom
i'm like he could bring aids he could
bring gonorrhea or whatever
then she's like oh no but you know she
accepts i'm like i'm not here for the
stress no oh well i'm like what did you
expect yeah exactly
yeah so would you do it yeah would you
do it with rules that you agreed on no i
wouldn't do it
i have a high disgust factor i can't do
it yeah
so
question what if you never found out
does it matter
it does matter no it does yeah it does
i could i would i would burn the house
down if i found out you had a child with
another woman so i would burn that okay
so question question vice versa do you
are you will you tell the person you
marry your body count
i don't have one are you a virgin yeah
oh good
good for your
[Laughter]
tell your ig
[Laughter]
wow i don't think i've ever had a girl
virgin on the show
i know what about you guys yeah yeah you
want to tell him
um
if you wanted to know i guess so okay so
i always ask guys the same question does
her body count matter if you never found
out
yeah yeah it's not for me no it doesn't
it doesn't matter if you never find it
oh no no it matters
there was a time i used to simply say no
i'll be fine no it matters because
the bonding thing that you even talk
it's also the history of the person if
you want to combine your life that
person you need to know their history no
but i mean you knowing the body count
why does that matter that's part of
their history
that's part of their history crazy like
30.
it's part of the history i can't like
can i just intervene here i feel like
it's kind of like
buying a car not knowing the mileage
history so like it might have been like
fixed up and everything but at least you
need to know the tangible evidence just
for you to make a decision based on
whether you want it or not because it
could affect pair bonding some women
just like have issues with that later on
in their marriage because they've had a
high
body count so for you it's it's for your
benefit to know so i have a how old did
you say you are 27. well that's that's
very impressive for one number two for
two have you found that dating is it
hard as a virgin
yeah yeah what what challenges do you
find they like to try and find like
their limits like what they can do
okay
and then so they'll they'll keep like
pushing you push it like let's try this
no let's try that yeah yeah yeah cause
you know i've seen a lot of like very
very pretty virgins that are in the
church that have the same problems and
it seems like it's tough because
like those guys
don't want to wait for a virgin when
they could have the next girl for free
have you found that or no yeah yeah okay
go ahead and ask your question
would you you meet a guy that you really
like etc he's dating you he's happy to
wait with you
would you
be
open
for him to be having sex elsewhere until
you get married no
so you want him to be again disgust
factor i'm not here for it i'm i'm from
zimbabwe i came here when i was 14. so i
grew up on like when you watch an advert
there's like an ads aids
campaign video something like oh you
have to get your partner tested so it's
like ingrained in me like i'm not here
for that i don't want to like
ask you can you go to the clinic and get
checked as long as i'm not here for that
let's say you like him and you trust him
right you trust his word so if he says
okay like i'll always use protection i'd
never put you at risk right
but obviously
understand it's amazing that you know
you've done that for yourself but
obviously the average person that we
live in very different times right now
that's why i won't ask him to do
something in in this level that i can't
do
like to me it's like a self-control
problem
for him
it's a heart it's a very hard sell i
think i know that's why it's difficult
because it's like saying because i think
it's like if he knows he's a like to be
with you he has to go vegan
yeah but the commitment doesn't start
they feel quite traditional come in
doesn't start till that rings on your
finger yeah not really yeah so until
that rings on your finger he's not
committed to you yeah getting to know
each other right yeah but you're saying
that even when he's not committed to you
you don't want him he want him to be i
would prefer that he doesn't do that i
know but is it a write-off for you
it would be that's a hard seller i know
can i i know i'm well aware of that yeah
so um would you be would you marry a guy
quickly
so he he's yeah
cause i know christian
i'm just saying quickly that's what
christians do all the time they'll get
married in like like okay
three months three months would you
marry that you just met him three months
later would you put it
it depends
yeah
i probably would okay i know people have
done it i probably but it really depends
on a lot of things okay yeah put a one
in the chat if you're trying to
would you also be open to
an arranged marriage if your parents
found someone that that they could then
bring you guys together both i would
only trust my dad to do that i won't
trust my mom i love i love her but i
wouldn't trust it to raise those yeah
dad knows best have you dated outside of
the church or would you only date a guy
in the church i've dated outside the
church before yeah okay just to see okay
what what is it like someone in the chat
said virgins tend to try to date men who
are bad boys or men outside the church i
don't like bad boys no okay i've never
liked bad boys i like it sounds weird
but i like squares i don't like
emotional anxiety from someone so bad
boys they bring anxiety i don't like
that okay okay fair enough that's that's
really good that's like very impressive
um i'm gonna read super chats for a
second you're going to get all these
people in love with you
oh i can put up the chat oh yeah that's
great thank you can you just remind the
chat what the chart was okay guys so um
ish is going to show um the sexual
market value chart and this is a chart
made by rolo tomasi basically showing
um
men and women's value in the dating
market
so yeah this is what we were talking
about earlier if you guys wanted to see
it
do you want to talk us through it before
we read super chats or just um no i mean
i don't know what else what are we
talking about do you guys agree with the
chart like you would say at 22 as most
girls peak
yeah
yeah at 12. so 22 most girls people okay
would you say it would you need to alone
or within that range roughly
okay
would you say you're left over by 35
yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is geriatric
pregnancy is like 35 or 37. i think it
depends
so for example my dad met my stepdad so
she met him when she was like 34 35
and they basically had a great you could
say marriage like 13 years before he
passed away last year but he was
literally the top tier guy
mechanic earning all that good money but
also taking care of the family and yeah
so i think it just really depends on the
person but that's
but that's more the minority rather than
majority so i understand that too so yes
you would say for the most part for the
most part yeah yeah i think if you're um
i think if you're talking strictly
physically attractive
then
yeah
for i think for most women then yeah
they're probably gonna you know their
highest their peak the season of their
peak is going to be in their early to
mid 20s but
i think any man who is looking for a
partner knows that a woman's value isn't
just in her looks
and so if he's going to choose her
there has to be more than that and i
think
just in my experience
that while they can be very attractive
women who are 22 23
a lot of them don't have
they haven't developed the mindset to be
a good partner yet
so
yeah as long as she's attractive fine
but yeah if we're talking strictly
physically attractive then yeah of
course my question to you then is that
don't you think if you find a woman that
is willing to be submissive to you you
can train her in the way you'd like her
to think in a certain way because at
that moment when she's being submissive
to you she's putting all her trust in
you and at that moment if she's putting
a trust in you then she'd be able to
listen to the things you say
do the things that you'd ask her to do
without
little to no questioning and so you can
find a woman at a certain age that you
like with the beauty that maybe you
missed out on with another woman yeah
yeah and then get one i think i think
there can be an element of that but i
think there's and this is why i think
men or masculine feminine complement
each other there are things that women
bring that men just don't are not aware
of they don't like they don't expect do
you know what i mean so a woman who has
that natural initiative to
um
to be an asset to her man's life in ways
that he does he didn't even realize she
could i think that's something only
women can know if i'm being honest i
think there's an element of you can you
know guide her to be the kind of partner
you want if she's younger but
regarding the training i don't know
maybe in western countries
that's that's not very appliable
nowadays because if you go to university
and you go around asking them questions
about modern dating whatever
you're not going to find someone who's
very
appliable to train based on how these
how they view things and talk and
whatever so you're going to have a
difficult time with that so i wouldn't
go to a university looking for that
person
but most of them were there like 21 most
likely that's where you would find a
bunch of them that is true i think more
so than anything you kind of have to
understand that if you're looking to
date a certain type of person it's all
about strategic planning yeah you need
to position yourself in a situation
where you can find the type of woman
you're looking for now if the type of
woman i'm looking for and i'm not saying
i am personally no i'm saying if the
type of woman i'm looking for is someone
that um
is able to get on my page i probably
wouldn't go to university where
the things are happening
um but it's just strategically where are
you positioning yourself to find the
type of women you like or as a woman i
say to my sister are you positioning
yourself
in the positions yeah to find the type
of men you want
so yeah yeah
okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
sec guys um if you have a comment that
you want read said send a super chat all
super chats are going towards studio
updates we want to get two more cameras
we talked about ish i think two yeah
cameras yeah two more cameras i know we
got issue camera you guys are excited
but we're gonna we're trying to get two
more just to get better angles um on the
people over there like the far angle to
whoever sits there okay
king darius buddy and also stop roasting
me reading these in the chat i'm so
tired of y'all i do the best i can
all right king darius buddy
buddy doesn't know any women
it's in their looks
humboldt shark won
i don't see virgin girls requirements as
a hard sell there's a difference between
between smv and marriage market value
king darius virgins tend to try to date
men who are bad boys or men outside the
church virgins need to date church boys
and stop fantasizing about having men
that are attractive to the majority lazy
artists how old is the virgin we demand
to know
d royal d royal this firefighter makes
over 130k what's up how you doing
um
hingo morales hi pearl how tall are you
you look tall as f i'm like six foot i'm
just under six foot um sentience what's
up sentience
he's been here he's been here
yeah yeah he's been here since the
beginning
um okay he sent three so they're all
modern women are confusing to most men
plan the date but don't tell me what to
do i can pay for myself but i expect you
to i don't need no man but shower me
with attention men be unapologetically
masculine she submits or she's for the
streets regarding men criticizing
females when they are not in a superior
position two points if men strive for
money and things to attract females what
incentive do men have to improve when
most women have higher body counts than
the holocaust
and men are constantly reminded to
self-improve to avoid being ostracized
from society and personal reason and
satisfaction first family with women
last women are byproducts of success
cheers gents focus on yourself and even
even when you don't want to
90 free toe pay [ __ ] i make 45 k 6 4 and
280 pounds i love redheads um navy man
officially a pearly member now and guys
join our memberships if you want to see
me rap you guys think i can't rap
you think i can't rap you think i can't
freestyle ish
guys
guys you want to see her rapping i'm
telling you now join the members yeah
join join we're going to drop a vlog
we're also doing a behind a
behind-the-scenes video on wednesday
where me ish and jess are going to sit
down we're going gonna order pizza and
just hang out answer your questions in
the chat it's a members only live stream
um
yeah so all super chats go towards that
um i think i got
oh no that keeps going 90 free toe pay
pearl likes apple pie free oh free taupe
oh free toe pie my bad my bad frito pie
okay 90 frito pie 1 to 10 is homely 11
to 20 is all right fine looking 21 to 30
is beautiful patrice o'neill happy you
saw his him finally but watch his debate
against dr z
vincent dalasal big chicks have opinions
but nobody cares pearl knows that as a
former whale
congrats congrats pearl on losing all
the whale blubber looking good thank you
um
look at it look at he said what it was i
i am mad about it i was um break cormier
i love how women cannot separate what
men and women see as attractive money
makes you look better that is a very
female point of view not a male point of
view so many women on the show make that
mistake
for females what do women actually lo
when do women actually love a man for
what they are after they get abs after
they get confidence good credit outfits
be honest what do you we'll answer that
quick
when do you think women do you think
women can love a man for who they are
yeah yeah yeah why not so a homeless man
a homeless fat man on the street no no
something's wrong as to why you're there
so
you sort that out
but no
not homeless
do you mean like love as in being a
partner or just love as in general just
like love like unconditional love
i think yeah you can just love anyone
yeah so your dude
you fell in love with have a couple kids
he gets fat and homeless
you in
yeah i mean otherwise why would i be
with him you know like
yeah like something must have happened
but yeah and get to that position in
between like what what happened there
okay come on are you saying after we've
had yeah
yeah and and it's not changing no build
a man
but how did that happen i wouldn't let
that happen
there has to be issues
fall off every day you know
the giving fat thing uh i mean first of
all i would like to just simply put out
that yes women can love a man because i
am a living example of a guy who's fat
old and bold and i still manage to find
women to love me so i myself do believe
in the power of the fact that women
don't just look yeah but you have other
characteristics though well
he also said your dating strategy was
that you're a provider yeah so you need
to understand that is where your bag is
the moment that goes away you'll
understand what we're talking about yeah
that's true definitely but but generally
as far as looks are concerned yes i am
thank god that women don't just go for
looks because if if i had to date in the
mail side of the dating game i'd still
be a virgin uh but as far as um uh you
know
everything else i mean it's it's hard
because i'll be honest i have seen women
especially in the middle east especially
in in places like iran and afghanistan
where they are really death to us part
they don't
just you know the guy has lost
everything he's he used to be a farmer
now the farmer's dried up and the the
family are still holding on can i ask
you a question
do you think that's because
excuse me do you think that's because um
excuse me
i'm lucky
we got this we got this do you think
that's because culturally divorce is
incredibly frowned upon over there yes
yes yes so because
if if
if divorce wasn't frowned upon over
there
like the way it is here
i would question how many of those women
would actually stay especially if there
are other more eligible options for them
but the thing is that's human nature if
there's always an option most people are
inclined to take it but this is where i
guess this this is why a lot of the
stuff we talk about here is i'll be
honest i found that our 99 western
problems these are not necessarily
transported in the east even even in
places as far as china but you're right
as far as like japan and south korea
very westernized asian nations they have
similar problems to the west well i've
just found that men like women can love
one guy at a time where men can love
multiple women
so like like you can just exist as a
woman
and a guy will love you but men have to
be something
for to even get you just like chris
rockstar right so so and that's why i
say like men and women don't love the
same
exactly like chris said only babies dogs
and women are loved unconditionally yeah
men are loved for what you can bring to
the table preach yeah that's true okay
so so you say yeah because i'd be out
i'm gonna be honest he's he's homeless
and fat now i'm out what do you guys
you're saying but you you mentioned that
obviously you had kids
you obviously may be married and whatnot
so if you have all those things how
about the characters
and then you become if you're if nothing
is changing you're really pushing it
yeah whatever that situation i'm also
harming the kids like
good answer good answer good answer good
answer go ahead
oh um
you know i if we have kids i guess i
wouldn't leave but he wouldn't be
homeless
yeah he wouldn't be fat
that just would never happen she said
wait no my words
one day and then tomorrow let's just say
i don't know he could have a drug
problem or whatever and now you are
homeless you've got nowhere else to go
you don't we're all homeless obviously
how can your husband be homeless and
you're not homeless that doesn't make
sense you're all going to be homeless
together
we'll be homeless together so in that
situation you're definitely going to
leave especially because you've got kids
you're not staying around you're going
to let my man be homeless by himself
probably see if you can get him in a
halfway house but you're going to let
him do his thing and you're going to
continue raising your family as it
should be and that's probably a
separation maybe yeah a separation not a
divorce you could still yeah exactly in
operation as opposed to like actually
like well if you don't want to change
what if he still wants to be outside
soho then you're done
and he belongs to the streets
yeah exactly yeah exactly
i say women should leave bombs the same
way yeah men should leave fat chicks
yeah it's if you don't want to work she
doesn't want to get in the treadmill i
feel like it's the same yeah
same
the the zasian 12
one thing i find is quite interesting is
that women rather watch shows with lots
of drama and tearing each other apart
then to watch shows where they come
together example examples the
kardashians versus the wnba why
that question yeah
i think that's all good why do you why
do you so why do women prefer shows
where people tear each other apart like
the kardashians versus the wnba where
they're coming together
yes i'm saying a bit of tea
i think that's just i think that's just
if we're making generalizations women
loving drama as opposed to sports yeah
yeah
yeah i think that's so true because like
in sports it's also tribalism like one
one team versus the other and the same
thing with oh babe bethany versus
terry or whatever
same thing it's a different type of
tribalism that people like to watch
okay um james sharp married man here a
feminine submissive woman with a
backbone is more respected than
independent woman because the former is
more authentic simply too awesome the
cost of submission was asked by kevin
samuels this is going to be a great show
please push the concept even further um
vincent dalasal she likes to argue just
to argue cole a hundred dollar super
chat before the show even started
uh he's just no respect thank you very
much i'm gonna refresh it real quick and
then we'll get to the next question guys
like the video how many people are in
the chat right now one thousand nine
hundred we need to have a thousand likes
come on guys that is the number one
metric you that youtube uses to push out
our videos so like the video a like is
free you don't even have to pay you just
like it takes a second okay 90 free free
toe pie not my question i asked when it
not if um are you m.a hey pearl we
demand to know are you down for the
swirl um guaranteed success um pearl how
often does the top of a man's head
factor into you finding them attractive
like
your face is it no the top of a man oh
top their heads yeah they still got hair
they still got hair i think i don't know
when i was a kid and i made like my sims
husband he was always bald
[Laughter]
what what
better bachelor's watching
zentian stop roasting me pearl now we
just have to ash return the camera and
get our rosetta stone course in the
english language
i'm a good reader damn it
you want ish to read again no
hey don't need to come for me like that
guys just don't go back to like may's
episodes wasn't great
hit that like button
king darius buddy doesn't know any women
oh in their looks okay i'm done
okay um
so we agreed that i'm shocked that
everyone said that 35 and over is a
leftover woman
i am i'm shocked because women whenever
i bring that up it's always like no but
they're the ones that are left over
everyone picked the ones they wanted and
then that's what's left over
oh okay so i think they've got no hope
don't say no
when you're playing sports i just said
it's time to end yeah it's like it's
happening it's time to put yourself on
sale
you're like the thing is
leftover pizza
people will still buy it just at a
discount
the thing is the very things
men value in women decline
exponentially after 35. it's especially
child bearing which is one of the
biggest things
women don't just lose a little bit of
value as far as like from 35 to 36 to 37
they almost double in every year in
their in their loss of of their if you
like value for men so the every year
from 35 onwards you are doubling how
your your effectively your sexual market
uh downfall
and so by time you hit 40
barely any men are
as in again
let me let me caveat this we're talking
about high earners high level men those
one percent 10 percent guys not your
average joe every average simp will you
may find the same average because the
average is the majority but what i mean
i think if we think about just because
economics right economics is all about
supply and demand in it so it's all
about
who wants and what they want so to say a
woman is expired it depends if you're
looking for a child-bearing man and
you're 35 plus then yes
that's a bit much darling a childbearing
childhood i mean sorry sorry a man that
wants children actually in this day
[Laughter]
a man that wants children and you're 35
plus and that's probably the wrong zone
for you darling that's when you need to
have a reality check and realize where
you actually are but sometimes you can
be a 40 year old man who's already got
children from previous relationship
you're not looking for kids anymore very
true you're looking for a good woman to
settle down with and just have life live
lavish go on a cruise and do whatever so
you don't care about her whether she can
bear children anymore you might not even
care too much about her looks because at
the same time you might not even be a 10
out of 10. you might not consider this
to be a 10 out of 10. you might see
yourself you know what i'm only a five
so
isn't that but at 35 that's what men's
peak is
so typically they want younger women
that the thing is going to say i think
he has a point you know so what i said
earlier about the mindset and kevin
samuels actually said this so rest in
peace to the godfather
he said that a lot of guys especially
into their early 40s where they've dated
very attractive women they'll like
they'll go down and look because they
just want a woman to be nice to them
do you know what i mean and i think a
lot of guys experience that
the most attractive women who get a lot
of attention because maybe they put
themselves out there and stuff because
they're getting a lot of attention and
feeds their ego etc understandably so
they actually don't um
they're actually not that nice they're
not that kind so i think there is some
value in
if a woman has the right kind of mindset
if even if she's older
for some men that's actually better than
a young attractive girl
right who maybe is a is a headache i've
heard the opposite that younger women
are easier to mold and that older women
are stuck in their ways
i think i think that i think that
element is true but
i i think especially younger generations
like
where
the younger the generation the more
entitled they're likely to be this is
what i'm thinking because nowadays i
think the younger generation they feel
like
this is what it is this is what it
should be city girl life this is how it
should be until i decide that it's the
other way around so i think they're a
lot more stubborn than we give them
questions
a woman in you could like you even said
a woman who gets to her mid-30s she has
a reality check and i think that's
actually why most average guys are
are nice because guys have a very early
reality check in life
yeah
d okay question for the man i'm going to
ask you guys this first
do you want a woman to settle for you or
you to settle for a woman
i would rather settle for the woman than
i would settle for i have to be
her top choice yeah 100 so you you'd
rather you'd rather go down i'd rather
go down yes okay
well i mean i think i think for my
situation it's never never been really
it's the the it's not a choice per se it
you have some control over the the types
but really
the woman is the one who makes the final
call
as far as sec dating sexual access to
sex all of that stuff is all in the
women's court relationships
not religious
that's the only part that's the only
thing at the end of the day someone's
more into the other one person likes the
other more than they like them it's
never equal yeah
so even in a relationship yeah
yeah it's true there's always somebody
someone's compromising yeah there's
nothing on one side at the start there's
always somebody that likes each other
some the other party more than the other
and i would prefer that back just going
back to the question i'll prefer that to
be the woman that likes me more that i
would prefer
back to the question i would prefer um
what was the question should be to be
her top job yeah i would prefer to be
her top choice personally that's just
that's just my own personal thing
would
and it's funny it's hard for men to say
that like the words subtle because like
men don't really use that word it's like
a woman that's how we say
even if it's true and they're kind of
funny what about you um
what was what would i would you rather
be settled for or settle for a woman
um i would rather settle for a woman
okay yeah so you guys would rather go
down and looks and up and how much she
likes you yeah for a relationship yeah
yeah relationship yeah long term it's
almost a must because if she's if she's
always thinking that she can do better
than you it's just this this this kind
of almost like this march to the
electric chair you can see it coming at
the end
you're just marching a slow march it's
that green line
as as you say that then would you not
then feel a frustration in yourself and
saying i can do better than you why are
you irritating me you're always nagging
me about this and that i can do much
better than that if she is though if she
is the type that is nagging you then
yeah you you you may get that impression
that like you know you know you know
what you know i'm better than you know
you know i i said settle for you right
i think it's easier for men to
compromise than for women it is though
to be fair i feel like men and
women yeah and because i think men it's
easier for me to compromise i think
i would say i'm going to say this i'm
biased but i think the best dynamic is
that he is her top choice and he settles
okay women
what do you guys think would you rather
a guy settle for you or you settle for
him
i think i'd rather
i settle no
i don't know
can i just add something yeah
i think the
issue that you have when a woman settles
for a man is that women are naturally
hypergamists so women are looking to
secure
the highest valuable man that they can
secure and so if she settles
and then finds a guy that she goes
he's better in
she's going to naturally want to go
yeah and then you have the issue where
you're breaking up a home
on the basis of your hypergamy which is
natural and so men don't naturally
yeah
they don't monkey branch yeah i guess i
guess that's why i'm like but you know
picky that's yeah i wouldn't you don't
want to be you know and i think it's
hard though because like as women we
don't like the word settle we don't like
to think that we're the ones being
that
settled
just a harsh word
you're settling for me like it's
someone's settling someone is it's
either it's either him or you
what are you picking him are you who's
settling he's settling he's settling
okay
i don't know
that's just a ton
i guess we asked we asked the tough we
asked the tough questions out here
i feel like because i have before
settled-ish
you didn't like it i'm sure
yeah yeah no i've settled for
someone that
so when you have when you say settled
what do you mean like was he ugly
yeah
i'm very okay okay very very very then
why'd you date him
because i liked who he was as a person
so but obviously it was all like a
persona and once i actually got to know
the person he was very
i don't want to use the word toxic
because i know how it's seen but he was
diagnosed with narcissistic personality
disorder so it's not like i'm just using
the term okay so it was very very toxic
so i did settle
so that's why i'm like i don't know if i
want to do that again or if i would
prefer it to be the other way around
yeah
yeah so so what do you got to pick one
i think the other one like put them to
they would settle for you yeah okay yeah
um
i would say
for the sake of my ego i would want to
be the one settling but
i guess it wouldn't work that way
because it just wouldn't so yeah i guess
i would want him to sell
i have a question for you go ahead
do you think
that
if a woman
settles for a man
then she is more likely to cheat on him
yeah
yeah that's exactly why i say
i
i prefer i would settle for her yeah
yeah i've seen that happen i've seen
that happen because i think if a woman
feels like she's got
her top pick
she ain't risking that for no one
because she knew how hard she had to
look for him
she ain't risking she ain't risking that
so but it works in reverse if a man is
settling for a woman that he thinks he
can do better he's going to wander his
eyes are going to wander and eventually
his other part
is settling in what aspect though i mean
if like issue doesn't look as good yeah
so let's put it this way let's say
you're a man in your early 30s you've
just started a career you're doing okay
but you're not doing great here's a
woman she's kind of nice looking but
she's really she's really into you she
absolutely loves you you get married
suddenly 35 40 your business is booming
you got the cars you got the house you
got the luxury you turn around and you
go you know i think i can get that
victoria's model now
um i can answer that um so what would
happen there is she'd divorce you and
she'd take off
and so and so they're not just half
alimony and she won't remarry so you're
paying for it until you die
so do you guys do you guys think with
that it makes sense for average men to
get married in 2022
yeah
the whole alimony situation yeah because
because women are incented you're
entering it you're entering you're
entering a contract where women are paid
to leave
you can have a peanut that has a 50
fail rate you can have a prenup i don't
know why average people don't have
prenups you have a prenup they're not
just for rich people yeah but i'm saying
that's not one it usually costs like uh
last i checked it cost like ten thousand
dollars to get a pre-nup
and so that's one barrier and then the
second barrier is that
you know
the it's not foolproof yeah they can't
they can there's a lot of ways around it
and the laws tend to favor women
so in 2022 do you think it's
fair for the average man to get married
with the laws being how they are where
women are paid to leave i wouldn't say
oh women sorry women go i wouldn't i
don't know if there's the right word
maybe wise but then again it's it's all
dependent on
the women you're with like
i'm pretty sure you would know her
enough before you propose to her and
yeah like do you do you think women can
hide their intentions
yeah but only for so long yeah you can
yeah you can pretend for so long like
i've dated a guy who just pretended to
be very nice and very you know gorgeous
whatever and then that only lasted for
six months because okay the the mask the
veil has lifted because you can only
maintain that for so long so i think
that's a very feminine point of view
but i
like because you're thinking like men
because men in general can only hide
their masks for so long
but women can hold them for longer and i
there's this i went to this um donovan's
convention there was a dude who's
married to a girl for years and she
divorced him and killed his dog wow wow
what yeah this is just
average joe
yeah wow and and so and to me i'm like
i've seen girls completely switch up so
quick like in a way i've never seen men
well i've seen one or two guys
but in debt like for the most part i see
girls doing a lot more so i can
understand like why men wouldn't want to
get married in 2022.
it's it's risky like
no matter what you do you can there's a
risk of being cheated on there's risk of
all sorts of things yeah you know
if you want security and you want to
combine your life with that person
i don't know i think it's worth getting
married yeah it's risky here now sure do
you think that if less men got married
maybe it would incentivize them to
change the laws
you know
i wouldn't say it's like for men to get
married i mean that's the thing with
like for example like men's rights
issues they don't lobby women lobby for
the things that they want men don't
gather and lobby for the things that
they want you could easily like get if
like a community of like 10 000 men if
they wanted to
get together and and lobby the
government to have like i don't know
mandatory like um dna testing when
you're born you can have that but men
don't do that there are there are men's
rights organizations actually there's
ones in the uk and there's ones in the
u.s yeah there are few but the problem
the problem is nobody cares and men are
seen as expendable yeah so so like
people don't care when men are suffering
there's a reason there's always women's
shelters and there's no men's shelters
it's not only that i'm sorry personally
i think that will be in society today
that will be seen as very toxic if they
was put into law that a man had to get a
dna test done for every child he's got i
don't know i don't feel like the law
really looks at a man's feelings when it
comes to certain things in a
relationship in terms of their kids and
all the all of the other stuff as well
you know in terms of just custody as
well
not saying
it's one of them ones where
the majority of the cases is what it is
majority among them that split up from
their women they ain't really worth the
salt it is what it is i get it but then
there is
the few
that come through the few that end up in
these situations where they got to leave
the misses or this and that and there's
just no protection for them all the mrs
can say what she wants to say she can do
what she wants to do and there's nothing
out for them to for them to be like okay
i'm going to go to my lawyer and i'm
going to use this but at the same time
for example like the johnny depp
situation that's like a rare situation
where a guy actually wants to you know
sue her and
have her punished or take take
accountability for actions for example
some guys you know they break up with a
girlfriend and then she trashes her car
they never call the police
like you could just pick up your phone
and call the police because if you don't
do that she's going to do that in the
next relationship and she'll never learn
and do you think men are taken seriously
when they're victims of abuse
no
so why would they call the police if
they're not taken seriously i mean take
the action
so that it's but yeah but so so if
they've taken actions before and maybe
had friends that took similar actions
and the result was they weren't taken
seriously why would they do it it's not
even just that it's it's even worse than
that
men have called
the police on uh spousal abuse or women
their their wife you know girlfriend's
wife's going crazy and they're the ones
who get in ha end up in handcuffs in
fact there's been cases in the united
states where they've been shot because
they've called the police and then you
know the escalation happened and and the
man ended up getting shot out of that so
it is actually physically dangerous to
call the police on your on your female
spouse if if they're you know if they're
being physical on you and i was going to
say um back to your point about men not
lobbying i think i think men do lobby
but i think they do it in different ways
and i think
i think
what we see is when women want something
changed they go into the streets they
lobby together they're very vocal
men show through their actions so if we
look at marriage a lot of men are saying
okay you know what because of the way
the laws are right now they're not in
the street saying change the laws
they're like i just want to get married
do you see what i'm saying so i think
men do love it but they show through
their actions
they're not like out here oh let me
change this it's kind of more okay well
if this is how it is i'm gonna take
actions to prevent putting myself in
that position
whereas i think women what we see is
they're like no we're going to be vocal
in change and there's no right or wrong
but i think it's that
so they're not marrying it'll be a form
of lobbying yes yeah yeah okay also
there is there was a gentleman in the
house of parliament who is actually a
men's right activist and when jess
phillips was one of the mps who who
demanded to have a um i forgot it was
like a woman's day or woman's week where
they discussed women's issues in
parliament when he demanded to have a
men's day that he was mocked and laughed
at
because jess phillips said every day is
a man's day in this parliament
and so men's issues never get discussed
because every day is a man's day whilst
women actually had actual days set aside
for them to discuss women's issues
that's how it is
so with that information would you say
it doesn't make sense for men to get
married in 2022
i think i think it's still worth it
again
it's risky i'm just saying like what
didn't they it is risky why would you
say it's worth it
well
the social issue of i don't know well
child-rearing it's better to be in a
committed relationship together
um
that's why you know if you divorce it
significantly impacts the children um
psychologically emotionally all these
all these things so why would they do
that when most women will give kids
without marriage
that's also not good that's the thing
like you shouldn't you shouldn't be
going around getting kills pregnant yeah
what about you guys what do you think
can you repeat the question
do you think it makes sense for average
men to get married in 2022
um
[Music]
i think everyone's entitled to do what
they want okay so i don't really have an
opinion on that but personally if i was
to ever
consider that i would prefer to get
married
okay do you understand where the men are
coming from though when they say yeah
yeah i'm saying yeah it's riskier now
for them yeah you understand that okay
what about you um
for the average man i mean
i mean if you haven't got much to lose
then i don't see what the problem is
really because what is the woman gonna
take you for the kids do you have
your kids well yeah but
it would be beneficial for them to have
their dad in their lives so why would
you take the kids
away from their that because women are
crazy
i mean how how much those are how much
honestly honestly let's let's ask the
guys i date them what percent of women
do you think are crazy
honestly
no honestly honestly what percent of
women to the extent where they wouldn't
allow this to see their debt
this is okay i i would say i would say
i would say about 15 to 20
and the reason i say that
is because i think the more attractive a
woman is the more likely society has fed
her ego in certain ways which promotes
the craziness but i think women who deal
uh who
kind of understand how the world works
more reality as opposed to that hasn't
happened to them i think they're less
crazy
um for me from a woman's perspective
you can tell when a woman's crazy
like there's a there's
a way there's a look in their eyes that
the guy they're with they can't tell
like i've told my brother i'm like
there's a look in her eyes like she is
mental but here's the thing you look
again you're looking from a woman's
point of view we pick up on more social
cues than men do so for example if we
see a girl giving us a dirty look at the
bar
men don't see it they're like what are
you talking about she just looked at you
for a second but we're like oh no
you're you're ready you're ready to
fight over one
[Laughter]
so it's for us it's easy to see yeah but
for men
they don't know they're just like oh
boobs
okay i'll probably maybe say like
30 30
crazy what do you guys think i would i
would have said about 15 20 as well you
know i don't think that many just based
on the women that i've i know in life i
i genuinely
first the women that i know i don't
think any woman would hold a would hold
their kids away from the father by the
way but yeah i would just say twenty
percent for the sake of arguments on the
team i might be a bit controversial on
this one i would say hundred percent
it's just
they have different scenarios in which
they can be crazier or less yeah i don't
know if you guys have ever seen the
crazy to hot chart
yes
and so women are always at a baseline of
about four crazy anyway at all times
and then have the hot crazy line in
which you can then ratio the hot you
know you have the hot about eight or
nine hot but about maybe ten crazy or
eight crazes what you really want the
ideal scenario is a woman is about an
eight hot and about a maybe a six or
seven crazy a unicorn well no the
unicorns are about a four hot uh or a
three a five hot and and a nine crate
sorry a nine a nine hot and a five crate
crazy that's a unicorn uh anything below
that like it said in the hot crazy chart
there was a guy who had a woman who was
like a three crazy but a nine hot and
apparently that was probably a
transsexual because that that doesn't
exist it was probably a dude
that's a dude it's not a man it's not a
woman because such women do not exist no
i mean
on a serious level though but women i
think baseline are always because of the
flux because of the natural hormones
that are running through you every month
every 28 days or whatever it is
a woman can be insane
sorry
oh you would say yeah what do you what
do you think ish um i
totally have to agree with what you've
just said
i couldn't have said it better
yeah there's a flux where um
some women you'll never get to see it
most women it pops out from time to time
and you don't know where it's come from
um but yeah
100 of women
so anywhere from one and five to a
hundred percent is what was what the men
said
fair enough
it's like if you have to go into
something where you have a one it like
one out of five women might take my kids
are you gonna sign up
and i don't i don't like this reality
because i've always like my parents are
married i think it's better for kids but
like i can understand why men are
walking away
if the laws are literally paying you to
leave
can i ask a question yeah go ahead
uh
right
so i understand how important marriage
is to you
would you still
want
um marriage
if it was the way it was 120 years ago
so
you don't have the right to your own
money your own assets you are literally
the property of your husband who
who is chosen for you is shuttle right
and your job is to stay in the home look
after house look after the kids
under those conditions and circumstances
would you still be in favor of marriage
the way you are today
if i had that mentality sure because i
wouldn't know any different today
the mentality and awareness you have
today
i'll just say maybe i won't say yes
so i think you know how you're like okay
under those conditions because those
conditions don't really favor you
you're a bit retracting from what kind
of
not the way it does today okay
you're kind of retract you kind of
retract a little bit away from marriage
i think that's how a lot of men are
looking at marriage like in the
conditions that it is today
they're retracting they're like this
isn't a good thing for me does that make
sense yeah because the thing is i think
i think most young boys they do grow up
thinking they're going to get married
like i think most of us do think that
because we kind of said this is what you
do yeah we're told of marrying the
perfect girl blah blah blah
but i think as you know like i said you
know what i mean reality hits a lot of
men hard the reason why i say
yes ish
is
the way i want to live my life is like i
want a homestead
i want to live simply and all that stuff
like what is a homestead
like um when you just have a house and
you have a bit of farmland just not not
a lot of acreage or anything and you can
grow your own veg be sustainable by us
you know
live sustainably okay yeah
yeah that sort of thing so it's not i'm
not too far away from it obviously the
being chattel that's obviously
that's why i am ish
i wouldn't say yes today but of course
like i'm kind of there it's like very
trad yeah
sorry i just got a question um
i don't understand how is it that
marriage equates to stability i don't
understand that because
you can have a man and you can be with
him for or even a woman and be with her
for 50 60 odd years and never get
married and that will be your rock
you'll secure your provider you're not
going to raise your family have your
homestead and do everything but you're
just not married i don't understand why
marriage seems to be
a way to secure
the fact that you're with your partner
because historically it's worked better
that way compared to other versions of
um
other family versions out there has
historically the government pending
marriage this is why i'm not yeah it's
it's a government thing the whole
context of marriage is government it's
nothing to do i'll tell you i'll tell
you why though like in general because
women fear being left after we lose our
agency
that's why it's like it's like women so
that's why women hate
when um gary v
his wife that
gary when garyvee left for the younger
model basically or maybe she left that i
don't know what happened but everyone
all the women on social media were so
mad because she gave that man her the
most valuable thing she has which is her
looks and her best years
and then
so women are afraid that they leave and
they get nothing out of it basically and
they invest in a guy i'm not saying it's
right or it's wrong i'm just saying that
it is what it is i just want to put a
note out this concept of monogamous
marriage this is a relatively new thing
in human history majority of i mean
human they estimate maybe human beings
have been around for let's say 200 000
years
majority of that was either polygamous
or
um men were just single there wasn't
very few people this this concept of
single one man one woman thing this came
out of
uh sort of religion a lot of religion on
organized societies and it's only a few
thousand years old at best maybe maybe
even ten at best it's not the norm this
is why if you actually look at cultures
like the middle eastern cultures the
japanese cultures they have harems they
have geishas they had a
a rich man had
a plethora of women well was gonna say
in in the sense of
it's like yes and no basically it was
the men it was basically high value men
would have multiple women but the
average guy wouldn't i was going to but
the average guy died
yeah well the average guy never
reproduced mostly
and alone but the thing is though like
monogamy is the reason monogamy has been
pushed so much especially in religion or
whatever is because that is what
sustains civilization
if
if we left it the way it is now which it
kind of is you know society starts to
deteriorate when you have
a small percentage of men monopolizing
the majority of women which is why you
know
i think we've said this before you know
monogamy is almost um a redistribution
of sex yes that's exactly what jordan
peterson says well i think it's because
the issue that comes is when there's
um a small group of angry sexless men
like that's when you get
stability like instability in society
did you say small
is it small i don't know whoa no sorry
sorry large that's what i mean yeah a
large group of like you always said is
it
was it six thousand oh sorry i forgot
how many years eight thousand years ago
yeah um only 17 17 women would have
children for one man yeah one man so the
majority of human existence has not been
monogamous but i think the reason we
have
have a stable society we've got to this
point
is because monogamy has been the
the mainstream practice
i think if the mainstream practice was
polygamy i think societies would syria
and that's what has historically shown
with every other civilization to happen
because if you have a bunch of if you
have most men living the nick cannon
lifestyle with children in all over the
place you know broken homes those are
actually like he's creating broken homes
because he's not he can't be present
every single day for how many children
eight nine how how present do you think
parents really were historically
i think
they were quite present i mean for me i
would say if 17 if 17 women were
reproducing for one man
how could he be present for 17 kids
because that's that's the thing though
the reason why we push monogamy is
because it's just a better option the
children are better off you can pay
attention to them more you you know you
can
focus on whatever issues that they have
easily because one woman can only
produce so many children
yeah i think i think also so i would say
not not great back then how do you know
it's better
i don't know
if something works for most of human
history
how could you say it's better
it's just that there's i guess you can
just observe like i don't know historic
if you just see how people lived back
then
and you compared to now
i think it's a lot better now
you know in terms of
there's a lot more order now compared to
that time
um now with all the studies we do on
children it seems that this is the
better option because when they do the
studies they're also looking at single
mothers they're looking at um polygamous
families and all sorts of things and you
can see that there's documentaries it
would just be interesting to see um if
there's a difference in the well-being
of children in muslim communities where
they do have multiple wives
versus the west
even in two parent homes i would get if
i my gut feeling is telling me those
kids probably turn out better even even
with multiple wives i feel like this
whole this whole concept of monogamy
going back to banksy again it's a
western thing i don't i don't feel that
monogamy is essential for a child's
growth for that that child to have the
father around as it is it's society the
sight we live in today that makes it so
that our father has to be there because
now society is just so broken outside
that if your child steps outside without
a good mother and without a good father
really backing them up behind them to
teach them the way to go they're just
going to go left and that's the way it
is back in the day you could have a man
who's got 17 um 17 different baby moms
and his kids would go up fine because
society wasn't that bad where the case
that his sons or daughters would go
outside and just get screwed
well maybe that's also because that was
a norm back then so it was in another
time they would sit yeah
like
yeah basically society society as it is
today has changed and moved away from
the point where you could you could
raise a child in a single parent
household and it'll be fine but today
today's day well it wouldn't be a single
parent household then he they would
still have the father
they would still have someone to look
like i grew up in it with a dad that was
gone a lot because he was building a
business and we like we're all pr we're
all good well you guys met my family
they're they're chillin yeah yeah
yeah if you take it back even to the
medieval era and and you know uh
egyptians and the persians and the and
the babylonians and the medieval
europeans the fathers were off on war
campaigns for years at a time
most of them died in those wars and
never returned and yet the society of
western civilization didn't collapse
into some chaotic uh you know
hell hole
so i don't know if this concept of this
this to me this is a creation of of
probably the 50s sort of american
you know
father and a mother and a daughter and a
son and a dog in a white picket fence
that is not a norm i think i think i
think here's the difference and this
goes back to you asking okay one guy who
has 17 kids he can't be there for all of
them i completely agree
the difference
of today compared to back then was back
then we were raised in communities
so your whole family were around you so
even if your father wasn't there your
uncle would be a father figure your
grandfather would be a father figure you
would have
your family members
around you even if your actual
biological father wasn't there you would
still have if we're talking about the
male the male 3 you would still have
male figures however nowadays because of
technology like you know like my family
are from nigeria like some of us are
here some of us are there some of us in
the state people live in people don't uh
they don't have their their tribes like
they used to so i think that's why
nowadays
yes we could do the practice of one man
having several children etc and maybe
that would be okay
if we still were raised in tribal
communities where you had you know they
say it takes a village to raise a child
yeah but we don't have this
i think that's why
that's the difference why i wouldn't
work today and you think do you think in
muslim cultures it works yeah because
they still have because their families
they grew up with their families around
them they still have the village they
guarantee you they're going outside of
the village um back then they would for
example separate the the children like
for once the boys hit a certain age they
would spend more time with the men the
uncles the dad
all the men and then the
daughters once they hit a certain age
they will only exclusively spend the
time with the women
that's yeah so someone was always
present though yeah do you guys think
that high value men have the right to
cheat
because think about it think about it
think about it he works his whole life
right to become a one percent guy
multi-millionaire he's jacked he has
everything why would he settle for one
girl
i'm not arguing either i'm just playing
are we talking about like that guy who's
big on instagram
no no not andrew tate but there was
something cal calrasian i forgot his
name he's he's oh dan bilzerian that's
it someone like that man
private jets
uh he's a successful gambler you know
dabbles aaron
i don't know who that is i'll take your
words
yeah i'll i'll do i'll do michael b
jordan
why on earth why would he have one girl
i mean if he's operating like that
then i'll just be wondering okay why
working to that level if that's why okay
fine that's what you do that's what what
that's what's motivating you if it's
maybe you like what you do and
outside of the women
you know if you're working that hard
then that's a different reason you don't
think men work for women
i wouldn't say not all not exclusively
yeah so so the whole right to sleep with
multiple women then have to ask okay
that's the main motivator but then if
you're working hard similar level you
have you have other reasons most men
have different reasons what do you what
do you guys think
what do i have the right to cheat
and i'm asking you at that with a
question do you think that men work for
women to get women
yes i think 100 i think 100 i think men
work to put themselves in a in a
position where they can have sexual
abundance yes yeah it wouldn't i don't
think it is it's very um i think
straight to the point to say men work
for women yeah but like like i want my
man said there's a lot more complex
situations in yes men work so that we
can get the best of everything so we can
get the best house the best car the best
of what we want to get and a byproduct
of that well not a buy product but a buy
something of that would be then you have
the best woman as well yeah if that's
the case if it just happens to be you
enjoy what you do or you just happen to
have done something and it's resulted in
you earning a lot of money
and the byproduct of course will be
women
but that's the thing i just have to ask
like
if you want to cheat or have multiple
partners and okay what's the main what's
motivating you if it's women okay have
your women okay but if it's another
reason you just happen to have made a
lot of money
and
it's a byproduct is having more options
that's fine that's it it's perfectly
fine for me do you think it's fine
either way
even if he is working so if he's saying
i work hard so i can get a bunch of
[ __ ]
yeah yeah
yeah he's like
yeah that's that's yeah that's fine
it's for me it's very easy very black
and white there is only one reason a man
has a ferrari
and it's not because it's so just great
at driving and it's got no it's to get
women that ferrari a porsche these are
literally extensions of a man's uh man
uh this is just i mean these things were
not even would not even be being made if
you think if a ferrari was as popular as
a skoda when it comes to picking up
women men would bother buying for them
can i be honest i think that's that's
more the case a woman knows how much a
ferrari costs
as a man as a man
personally there's things that i like
because i like it it doesn't matter how
much it costs i just like it because i
like it yeah and if a woman knows how
much it costs then that's gonna hurt her
like me because how much it cost but i
got it for me i didn't get it
can i be can i could you give me an
example sorry
an example yeah something that you have
that you would deem somewhat expensive
that
you didn't buy for a woman you bought it
for yourself
i can give you this my house your house
okay
that helps though i'll give you an
example it helps what i'm saying it's a
buy product yeah yeah at the same time
you get you get a buy product from it
but i didn't get it to get a woman i got
it for myself that's what that's what
you have to check like okay
i didn't get the house full of it for
something else
about the ferrari maybe maybe using the
cars by example because i think the
funny thing is i think guys may
initially think oh yeah i'm gonna get
this car to attract women but actually
just attracts other men
yeah but because it just makes other
guys go yo man
that's a nice car no but you've seen it
yeah you've seen it yeah but how'd that
have that screenshot work out for you
[Laughter]
um okay chat
thinking who's going to watch this
okay okay i'll just be honest
um okay so basically i i was in la
recently um i won best act of one of my
films so i've been
thank you very much
so um i was having meetings i went to
l.a so i'm signing with the us manager
anyway
um
as
press goes on or whatever as you're
maybe an upcoming actor
there was this article you can search it
it's
lightcelebrities.com l-i-t-e
celebrities.com
um written about me
uh and it's like a it's like a website
for like up-and-coming like semi-celebs
don't know why i'm on there i wouldn't
say i'm that level but it's a nice
compliment
um
and it has like your career on there
family whatever right i don't know how
they find a lot of this stuff anyway
um
in the article it says
my net worth was something like three to
four million dollars
which at first i was like if that's true
then the government's taxed me way too
much because i need to find that money
uh but
so i just thought it was funny and you
know one of my friends about it anyway i
was in that a recently and i've heard a
lot about what girls are liking that a
you know because it's full of superstars
etc the city
so i did a little experiment
downloaded tinder right
took a screenshot of
the article where obviously it has my
image and it has my
net worth on there
and i put it on tinder i just thought
let me leave it see what happens
and oh god the results
i got way more matches
with way hotter women like nines and
tens and a few of them would message me
first
and i was like wow
that [ __ ] is true
there you go it was real that's
and some might say oh did you meet with
any of them the answer is no because
they'd be expecting me to fly them out
like a private jet and [ __ ]
[Music]
well i'm doing well
i ain't worth four mil
at least right now i'm too expensive
okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
second guys if you have any questions
you want me to ask put them in the chat
let me know
um edgar ryan it's called feminism guys
honest citizens
citizen polygamy meant men in power took
women away from average men by force and
other men were forced to be a you a
eunich you know they've been castrated
oh wow okay polygamy was not
not a choice women were forced due to
finance women were seen as property
chris mccarthy thank you for the super
chat lawrence bullock do they have
common law marriage in the uk i don't
actually know i don't know what's common
law marriage it's when you live with
someone over that's what i thought okay
yeah do you have that here
i think we do things have slightly
changed i heard recently but yeah there
used to be a thing if you cohabit for a
certain amount of time she is entitled
to uh
your you know treated like your wife the
household essence yeah it's still
difficult
yeah it's still it's still it's still
harder hard to get even without marriage
yeah that's crazy daniel um
i'm saying
they're like they're like twisting men's
arms you will be married
you will
daniel marriage has always favored women
um mar i can't read your name when is
the pearly waifu pillow gonna drop what
does that mean what's a waifu pillow i
don't know what that is
oh i think it's those um because in
japan they have these long pillows where
men can you know single people can just
hug them as they and their pictures
[Laughter]
merch okay can women lay off the we're
hormone hormonal so our emotions change
all the time so that doesn't make us
accountable it's a title excuse your
hormones change you're not on meth
um
87 a man was shot and killed by police
after his son called the cops after
seeing that his mother stabbed his
father the father who had a disability
had reportedly called the police over
the abuse prior
lawrence bullock
women that proudly say they will not
settle is a big red flag because the
fairy tale man they are always looking
for doesn't exist and they're never
satisfied michael federer 100 dollar
super chat
let's go
um
this is a cute conversation but the time
has passed for u.s and western women we
are going overseas and sisters it may
take three generations to get it back
we wealthy fit older men don't want you
and we have foreign women now
well lucky for you i am overseas
okay matt butcher bottom line is if you
marry and have kids or and or have kids
with a lady it's a gamble you never know
what you'll get despite the red flag
despite red flags the odds are against
you
um okay
let me just refresh it real quick guys
like the video come on like a like is
free how many people we got in here two
thousand
oh we got a thousand likes you guys did
come through last time i just exposed
myself depending who watched this video
so like the video please like the video
who's watching
i thought i thought you were single
what's going on i am single okay okay
that is what people are watching
[Laughter]
um okay why do you think that
men
are why do you think that men are
expected to deal with women's hormones
but women like us being hormonal every
month but women aren't expected to deal
with men's hormones that they're horny
who said that women don't deal with
men's hormone and horny woman well
technically yeah you'll be dealing with
that yeah yeah you still be dealing with
it do you feel like
do you feel like it's the same guys
no
no not not for the most part
men
men have to endure i'm washing my hair i
have a headache and all of that whilst
if
if
you know and the guy can't really say
look
it's that time of night for me
i need to have this whilst if a woman
just
basically goes crazy and
loses her collective [ __ ] every month
men have to kind of grind their teeth
nowadays they can't even say are you on
your period that is going to trigger
more [ __ ] coming your way just by saying
is it that time of the month love i just
need to know
thanks you have to download the app
yourself just so you know
there's no question you sync the flow
app together
i don't know i think women go through a
lot of biological you know
imbalances throughout the month and
yeah it is what it is i thought i feel
like if a man in the morning night
morning afternoon and night a woman
wouldn't give it but
a man would be happy to just if she's in
her mood and her you know i mean he'll
run tesco get her whatever she wants and
do whatever but if you say to the woman
yo i'm feeling a bit i'm getting your
knees and it's a bit
nah i got other things i want to do and
that's to say i don't know i don't know
i think because men you
it's in you okay
i don't know i think men
it's easier for men to be horny
it's because they're women but it's
because of our health yeah like i don't
it's our hormones it's our hormones the
basic question is or hormones the base
question is about hormones like women
men are willing to accept women's
hormones and the way they are at the end
of the month when it comes to a man's
hormones a woman's a bit like not in the
mood
even on the couch what i said would you
accept a guy cheating like they're just
they're horny just from time to time you
might [ __ ] a hoe
so the primary hormone right for sexual
arousal is testosterone
right do you know how much testosterone
the woman produces you can check this as
well
no it's i think it's like anywhere
between 50 to 100 nanograms do you know
how much men produce
it's up to a thousand
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying so
you know how horny you get
times that by 20. that's what i'm saying
men are who
but you dealing with his hormones
would be like well when he's horny
can he have sex with you or anyone else
that should do this okay okay do you see
what i'm saying
okay
but because when a woman has a period
meant to have the luxury of saying i'm
just gonna go out for a few days i'm
just gonna i'm gonna s out for like two
three days what you do your thing and
then you know i mean when you're ready
[Laughter]
like i mean i think women well i don't
know from my experience i'm more horny
when i'm on my page yeah you know like
coming up too men genuinely don't want
to access women on their period
generally when a woman is the most the
way it is unless unless your name is
dracula and most people don't
don't want to know this
you're very quiet
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i already asked the question
you agreed
how would you deal with a man's hormones
then
how would you deal with it like so what
i mean is he's incredibly horny you're
not in the mood
this is a recurring thing how do you
deal with his hormones how would you
deal with it here's a pornhub
subscription oh sorry i said the word
exactly
do you think corn has saved marriages
no
i think i think it's just saying i think
a lot of
um it is prolonged
angry men doing things to women against
their will there's actually statistics
on that where since they out
uh since the growth and and the
accessibility of uh
adult material uh it has actually
reduced or well i mean i don't know
whether it's a correlation
causation but
the the sexual assault rates have
dropped over the last 20 30 years
and proliferation of adult material has
been exponential everybody has it on
their phone everywhere now do you do you
guys think corn is cheating
no yeah
yeah i mean like
do you think do you think you're looking
for the perfect guy no not perfect i
don't see that i don't see the point of
doing it when you're married you have
someone to help with that but that's
because you're looking at it from a
woman's point of view but men they
always want to screw different chicks
because women were programmed to want to
be with one guy where men are programmed
to want to scream screw everything that
moves i watch this podcast where this
guy was married and he explained that he
had a problem with the fact that his
wife
um was okay with him using porn
sorry i'm sorry
um was okay with him watching corn
when she was around she she couldn't
care less that he's doing that and i
think she had a low sex drive or
something well that's probably because
he was disappointed he was in fact he
was hurt by the fact that okay you're
here and you're not offended by the fact
that i'm getting mine somewhere else
well i think it's probably that she was
sexually rejecting him that's really
hard that's how he felt that's yeah so
that's why that's my perspective like
why would you do that when
you get together but i'm saying it's
because they want to screw everything
that moves like even in evil in
evangelical christians 80 of them are
addicted to corn
yeah yeah so most even the religious
guys are watching it
because i mean they're human
yeah and so if they're not going to
screw all their chicks how can we be mad
if they're they're watching corn to try
to avoid that
i mean at the same time you're also
training your brain your brain is a
muscle
if this is what you're used to watching
this is just how you get yours
it's going to be difficult when you're
married okay you know you you probably
want a visual aid every time that's very
frustrating so i've heard it is a muscle
at the end of the day okay so i've heard
men
say that they keep old oh god old
pictures and videos and use that so they
don't get addicted to corn is that
cheating
i don't see the point of it when today
women dress more scantily clad you can
just take a walk
yeah but they can't do that on the
street yeah they can't take a walk no
but they they can't walk down the street
no doing that
i don't see the yeah i don't have i
don't see the point of having materials
like that in your house right materials
from a woman's point of view yeah but
like the men they're biologically
predispositioned to want to screw
everything that moves yeah and i totally
get that we we all have our hormones and
biological
drives and things like that but at the
end of the day
you know we can't let that lead us
right but don't you think in the same
way that he would have to put up with
you being different throughout the month
going back to the question maybe you'd
have to no i i don't let that lead me
either i'm i'm not an animal like i'm a
person like i can feel when i'm like one
month i may be feeling maybe irritable
or brain fog or something but i try my
best not to
let that lead me because yeah well he
could try his best yeah but you just
like you'd know like i'm sure he'd
understand okay this is her time yeah
she might have brain fog and then i
understand okay he's feeling some type
of way
i just think this guy doesn't exist
i don't know it's communication like you
know
this is why honestly a lot of like
pretty girls are single in the churches
because they are looking for this
religious guy that doesn't exist in the
west in the west i just wanted to
highlight the paradox here where
the ladies say well i or at least
certainly there was a lot of hesitation
about i can't cater to his hormones
anytime he wants because whatever mood i
might be in and yet at the same time
he's not allowed to even crack one out
to anything he literally has to be a
celibate when i tell him he can release
the beast and to be honest with you you
guys have to realize
it's a
mind
sort of
uh what's your scrambling thing to have
as a man to have your entire life
especially when you're young
dominated by this animal beast inside
your head going do it do it do it do it
get it get it get it it's constant can i
give you can i give you this example
it's personal experience um i was i was
working in france for a few months
recently
and there was a point where i was go i
was considered considering practice
practicing abstinence
right
um and
in that i was okay when i was walking
about and everything i was like okay you
know because it was summer so yeah you
know a lot of girls wear kind of scanty
stuff
and i was like okay i'm not gonna look
you know like because i'm like oh if i'm
gonna try and practice this i need to
try and work in this way right
it took more energy
not to look
than to just have a glance
as in like literally a girl will pass
i'm like don't look don't look okay
great another one don't look no no okay
great like it was by the time i'd gone
to the gym and come back
it was incredibly exhausting now that
doesn't mean you have to look in a
creepy way you can be like oh wow she's
a beautiful woman and you can just
appreciate the beauty that she's giving
for that day do you know what i mean
but there is something very primal in
men men are very visual creatures
and from that experience it was kind of
like wow it actually was harder not to
look like if a guy walked in this room
bullet naked
and i'm like looking at you it would be
hard not to look at his junk
it would take energy not to look that
exact feeling is what it's like for guys
for
especially nowadays because you know
like you said like you know like women
wear more stuff that's more thai and you
know most everything's so sexualized now
damn nearly naked at the beach
so it's like it's it's like
and real talk like it was i almost start
to i almost kind of resented being a man
for it because i was like wow like it's
such an innate thing
that is so difficult to
not just not to control but to contend
with
but it is just a real fact of being a
man
quick question what does
abstinence
consist of where you don't
do you're not sexual at all so you're
not allowed to look at women no fab well
it's not that you can't look at women
but it was like if you if a guy if
you're looking at attractive woman nine
times out of ten the first thing you
think about within the first 10 seconds
is what would it be like to have sex
with her
really is that really how what you don't
think yeah hundred percent
straight up why do you think like man
wait wait
[Laughter]
like you know if you're in a bar or a
club if a guy approaches you it's not
because he's approaching because he
thinks you have a nice personality
[Laughter]
they're really on it with the liking
today they get to one point too
one point well one thing that the lady
over there said which was very true
which is if you do ever agree to an
arranged marriage you would have your
dad
choose the man
i 100 agree because your dad would know
exactly what that man is thinking yeah
and the woman will never know what a man
it's impossible it is impossible as
empathetic as you can be as much as you
want to sort of put yourself in another
person's shoes you will never know what
it's like to have this beast in your
brain
constantly
between your legs really but it's
here constantly constantly it's a
constant nagging little thing that is
bugging you but also but also realize
it's that very thing that gives women
power
that's why only fans is a thing that's
why that's why instagram models is a
thing it's that exact
innate beast in them that thing that is
so difficult difficult to contend with
that gives women they pout gives women
the power they have ever made that's why
because if men didn't have it y'all
would have zero power over it mm-hmm
over men that's why porn stars are
female corn stars get paid far more than
male of course it's the only it's one of
the few industries where the women are
out earn men easily i mean i think
that's why the laws actually favor women
so much as men gave them that power
yeah like yeah because i think i'm a
female lobbyist
yeah i think i think men have an innate
instinct to protect women yes yeah and
that's that's where i disagree with a
lot of even like conservatives is
because they never hold women
accountable even when a girl is
sleeping around it's always oh what the
man slept with her
like oh you used her for her body it's
like ah she was horny get out
a man has very few options to uh when
when a woman gets pregnant once a woman
has a
traumatic
right and even even though it's even
though it's her choice and she made a
poor decision it's always
it's always one of the met well he
shouldn't have been sleeping with her he
shouldn't have stuck his and it's just
and it's just like well she made a
decision too no i have a i have a small
rant on this uh and that is
the the hypocrisy of this situation of
when when a man and a woman uh have you
know coitus and then the the woman turn
around go i want to keep it and then he
is in effectively indentured servitude
for the rest of for the next at least 20
years or 18 years of of that you know
child's life
and women go well you know you should
have so you are literally saying to a
man at the point where he could be drunk
or he could be just on drugs or whatever
and he's horny as crazy
that's the moment he has to make that
18-year life decision
whilst a woman has from literally date
one pregnancy to at least six months to
make her life choices she has
not been not only before and before that
birth control
literally a buffet of birth control
options you're saying you the man who's
drunk horny and is just trying to get
his leg over that's the time you have to
make life life and death decisions
life-affirming decisions i i
i
i fully
agree with what you're saying the caveat
to that is what i would say is this
met what does it mean to be a leader
to take responsibility for your team
and if men have historically been the
leaders
part of being the leader is you have to
hold yourself to a higher standard i'm
not saying it's fair
i'm not saying it's fair because i
completely agree if two people lie down
they both decided to but i think where
that comes from
is because men have always been seen
to lead and part of being a leader is
being responsible taking responsibility
for your tribe and your team that's why
i think where that comes from well okay
well even though she got pregnant and
she made a poor decision which is true
and nowadays because equality yet you
have to take accountability for that but
it's also like okay
but as a man who's supposed to become a
capable leader
he has to be take more responsibility
for the entire situation i'm not saying
it's fair but i'm saying that yeah but i
think it's just though there's a
difference between he should like if you
get a girl pregnant you should take care
of it i agree i agree but at the same
time
there's a difference between putting a
gun to a guy's head and saying pay for
it i think i should be able to have a
financial abortion yeah i agree 100
nowadays yeah of course as at least
have some parity of options the way
women have yes either with the fact that
they can abort they can
give it away for adoption women have all
of these options open to them a man
literally can't say i want this child to
be adopted the woman if she says i want
to keep it yours you're done what do
what do you guys think would you be okay
with that since we have the right to an
abortion they could get a financial
abortion where they don't pay child
support
i'm fine with like a fight a
financial abortion if
i don't know if this person isn't a
stranger to you
if that's the case like you already had
an agreement or whatever maybe she's not
even a girlfriend but there's a
relationship it's just sexual sure but a
relationship because that's the thing
though if you want to do a one night
stand i'm sorry you're gonna have to pay
for that baby why was that wrong
i think i think on both parts if it's a
one-night stand you're having sex with a
stranger you don't discuss let's be
honest if you're doing that so none of
you discuss
um have you been tested none of you
discussed um are you gonna where are you
on the pill do you even know her to even
trust that she took it because recently
what does she know so
at the same time both
why does she get a reward how does she
get money that's the thing though it's
why does she get money and he doesn't
it's not necessarily a ru it's a
financial reward for her but it's not
really
a hundred thousand kids
but it's not a social reward she's a
pariah
she is not necessarily not necessarily
in today's society god forbid you want
to slut-shame her yeah and that's that's
what i'm saying i'm saying and mostly i
mean
most girls will live with that for like
200k a year
i'll be a piranha in my life
yeah
so so why does she get a reward but
that's could you answer that question
why does she get a reward
for making a poor decision that's that's
that's the way the laws are said no i'm
saying but why
so you said you would agree with it for
a one-night stand that it should she
should get child support so since you
agreed with it why does she get a reward
for making a poor decision where men
have to pay i wouldn't consider it like
a reward necessarily because she 18
years of money
yeah i know it's a financial reward but
there are other negatives that come with
it
like if you're talking that can be
outweighed by
i know it's a fun i know but it's not
it's not really a perfect system even
for that for her i'm not saying i'm not
saying that like women who do that
should be rewarded drinks baby mama's
doing pretty well i know but again
there's no social reward for her she
wasn't she a corn star or whatever i
don't know yeah she got rewarded for a
bad decision so i'm asking you why why
do you why is it that the women
face no consequence and the men do
it's the again it's it's unnecessary i
agree it's unfair financially and sure
he should be able to
but
if you're if you're with a stranger
if you decide to both put your pants
down together yes with a stranger you
don't know how she's going to raise you
don't know what her values are you you
and she doesn't know anything about you
either
i'm sorry but you you've used basically
made a mistake both of you right he's
gonna have to pay she's gonna be a
pariah somehow whatever in some way
you know she probably won't get married
or whatever i don't know she might not
have optioned the best options that she
would have had before but now that she
has a child
you know in a one-night stand situation
but if you knew each other
i would say yeah have a financial
abortion because there's some rapport
whatever so so what would you define as
new each other i don't know i don't know
like
how would legally they they defer who
knew each other and who didn't
i would if
you know you know what in a perfect
world for those people
i would say maybe
some kind of evidence that it was clear
that he didn't want the child or she
didn't want a child but somehow she
changed her mind but it's there that
there was no consensus there so you
would say if they're in a relationship
no child support yeah but if it's a
one-night stand she gets child support
because like i'm sorry you you've both
you've both tripped you both you both
i'm saying like you realize you're
paying out bad decisions even more
it's it's a risk it's a like if if you
had rapport you would say okay
she you'd know okay she has had
if you're responsible if you're both
responsible she's on some kind of
contraception maybe it didn't work
whatever it's not 100 none of them are
yeah it didn't work the condom broke or
her thing it just she's the one is a
fluke the thing didn't work okay and
then fine okay yeah but so but
essentially in a one-night stand you're
saying she should get paid out
it's again yes yes or no yes okay yeah
okay go ahead
that was a long chance sorry
um in a one night stand i think no i
sorry
if you want if you want to make that
difference so do you think men should be
able to have a financial abortion since
we can have an abortion
i think if you want to do the special
law you can but it's the that's the
general question glenn yeah i think i
want to use the whole
i mean yeah i mean
yeah okay yeah you've got equal rights
right yeah at the end of the day because
i personally wouldn't want to have an
abortion
so but like yeah in the name of equality
yeah okay what about you
um can we just define financial abortion
again please okay so
if you get pregnant
you're keeping the kid
he says you know what i i didn't mean to
get you pregnant i want nothing to do
with this kid he can sign off financial
rights
and parental rights yes yeah i think
i'll say the opposite um
to what rue said which is i think if
it's a one-night stand
i think he has every right to do that
just because
yeah they're both consenting adults but
as a woman you have more to lose
going into the situation so you should
be more
cautious and you know
be responsible and if it happens then he
has the right to say no i don't want to
be involved because that's what it was
at the time and that's what it is but if
you're in a relationship
and you know this one time we've done it
and we've gotten pregnant when we've
done it many times before and i haven't
then
i don't think he should have the right
to
bail out of it because we were doing it
before the only difference is i've
gotten pregnant now
so
you should just be responsible for it
just like i am did you did you know did
you know there are entire reddit threads
of women talking to each other trying to
figure out how to trap a guy that
they're dating
yeah and there are men that talk about
how women will steal condoms
and so so the whole point and it's okay
a lot of people have never thought about
it like this is your incentive if you're
paying out bad behavior
you're paying women to make bad choices
instead of saying you made this choice
to deal with the consequences
i mean it also happens the other way
around i feel like not just women do
that in terms of condoms guys also
stealth so like take off their condoms
midway and you don't if you're not
really in your sixth sense
you could also get pregnant women
women can actually have a man brought up
on grape charges yeah if they take them
yes
yeah so men have a consequence for that
women
there's nothing yeah there's no no
there's no that's our support that's
what the function of guys one at a time
sorry i can't hear a word you've just
said sorry karen
don't get me wrong like i obviously
believe
women are responsible for
their wombs like that's why i'm not
active
like i'm responsible for it yes like
when i want to get pregnant that's my
decision right yeah i understand the
the consequences and all that stuff it's
just that you know again my my exception
is a why night stand
you know in society as a man
what the consequences are you know you
have a woman you know
right in that situation because you're
strangers you know i i've never had a
situation where people just go to a club
they meet up they want to have sex and
then they go are you pro-life for
pro-choice
if something happens here if your
contraception doesn't work
like that's the thing though
but if you okay okay we're done with the
club i i'm feeling you i want a physical
relationship
then maybe you can have a small
discussion about things if you're
responsible but after after that i can
understand the situation
why you'd want a financial abortion
whatever so so why is she entitled to
child support in a one-night stand why
does she deserve it
in a one-night stand yeah because you
said
again i don't think she deserves it i
don't i don't think they so she would
get it so therefore she would deserve it
because that's how the system is i'm
just basing it on how things are no but
i asked you how you would make it and
that's what you said so i i wouldn't say
i wouldn't say yeah i was just basing
like on how it is like yeah of course
pay for it
you're both irresponsible
you're both strangers so now you're
ending up having to raise a child
straight right so you would agree then
that he should be able to have a
financial abortion when he doesn't have
to pay child support yeah i don't think
she's entitled to it she was being
irresponsible in in in most parts of the
world you wouldn't be getting that okay
okay can i pose a scenario because uh a
lot of the ladies you said you said that
in a one-night stand
um
he can have a financial abortion whilst
in a relationship he shouldn't do you
also agree that in a woman's scenario if
in your particular ideal scenario if a
woman is in a relationship with a man
and she gets pregnant but she wants to
abort but he wants to keep it would you
allow him to keep
force her not to have an abortion and
keep the baby because he wants to keep
it
it's a complicated one but i would say
you are entitled you are entitled to be
a father i think it would depend on the
woman's reason for wanting the abortion
in that circumstance just based on what
i think it's very sticky but i think
it's the woman's reason if she's like oh
i'm too young to have a child then that
that's not good
but what i've noticed is you can you can
say a woman
you said in a one-night stand he can
have a financial
abortion that's fine but in a
relationship he has to then take the
responsibility but yet at the same time
that woman still has even in a
relationship the option to abort so
you're not taking away the woman's right
to abort but you're taking his right
away from having a financial abortion i
think it's wrong to
take away his right to be a father if he
wants to be have the baby
and let him raise the baby but that's
what i mean would you say that if
if a man says i want to keep the baby
could you just carry you know take the
pregnancy to full term yeah and let me
take care of it yeah would you say that
the woman should then at that point not
have the right to abort
um
yeah i guess so yeah yeah
okay that's at least for parody
the point of the abortion is to get rid
of the baby so there's a second means of
doing it without killing the baby
give birth to it with the woman get rid
of it
and still pay child support sorry
what oh yeah yeah yeah
again yeah
the baby that you didn't want yeah so
would the women now pay child support to
their managers
the way it's actually set up is based on
who's taking care of the child full term
and who has the most money if she has
more money i don't know if if he's
taking if i had more money than you but
you had the child for me you gave me the
child would you pay me child support if
you make it it's an exception it's not
the rule most but if you just most men
don't win in those cases yeah but if you
wanted to take care of the baby that
means you're taking care of the child
full term that means the woman will be
paying child support because you you are
the carer you would need support
so actually if she gave birth to baby
and gave it to you she would have to pay
child support
yeah
and that's why men don't win in most
court cases
and that's why they bought them
so i know if you want me to give that
baby to you i'd be paying for it because
you'll be the main carer yeah
i think women abort them actually
because they're hypergamous
they want a guy that makes more women
one out of three babies um that are
aborted up from women that make over
forty seven thousand dollars per year
one out of three we're only only
eight percent of um babies below the
poverty line are aborted so it's like
mostly upper yeah
yeah okay i'm gonna read the super chats
and then we're gonna close out the show
everyone can give any final thoughts
that they have
ryan phillips i left my girl because she
was cheating on me we had a joint
mortgage and a kid together and she
hasn't let me see my son in over four
months we're waiting on the court i've
heard so many stories like this like the
last couple months it's actually insane
jay alexander 12 years of marriage two
kids all my time and resources with no
lovin she just admitted she was done
with the marriage years ago and never
told me 90 free free toe pie
stick to the question stop letting them
change it um charles vasquez another 100
pound super chat let's
go um may the beef continue ninja
watchers we up stop it stop it subscribe
stop ninja watch it
the audacity of you guys um kt this week
you know actually maybe go a little
slower because we have to do a 24-hour
live stream at 250 and i don't really
want to do that
that's okay um k2 the swiss the average
joe you spoke of pearl is terence pop on
youtube um c2 j can you react react more
to its complicated content please yeah i
love it's complicated so we probably
will in the next couple weeks edgar
reyes it's called feminism guys honest
citizen citizen polygamy meant men in
power took women away from average men
by force and other oh i read this one
already let me refresh it and just make
sure guys while you're at it like the
video where are we at we're at 1.3 k
likes can we get to 1.5 before the end
of the stream
um okay that's
okay i got all of them so
why don't you start say any finals final
thoughts you have
what was it what was the original topic
oh uh cost of submission yeah it costs a
submission submission
um
uh final thoughts is
cost of submission um
if a woman chooses the man
then
part of her choice in choosing the man
is
his earning potential or how much he
earns so i think if a woman wants a man
who
can lead and she wants to submit to her
man
then that comes in her choice in terms
of
who she chooses and how much he earns
that makes sense
um
cost of submission
um
yeah finance is a factor for women it's
a major factor
um but obviously with other with women
as well they're plenty of intangibles
that we look at
yeah
final thoughts yeah
and if you have any social media you
want to plug yeah you you might you want
to put in your instagram you want to put
on your instagram
yeah
his entrance is about to wipe you off
yeah
tell me your instagram it's a nintendo
underscore jay underscore
go ahead uh final thoughts um
it's been a good show i enjoyed the
talks that everyone's had speaking to
them i've enjoyed what everyone's had to
say and yeah it's just been really
interesting to hear different thoughts
and
perspectives
so thank you yeah thanks for coming
um
i would say
similar to who really i mean money is
definitely
a factor but women also care about other
things amongst that as well so
um
and
um
yeah that's it really yeah
um okay uh final thoughts of
sub price of submission is um
is incredibly relative uh and subjective
you can go to the middle east gentlemen
and process submission is simply a
british passport
so if you can get a visa for a girl
that's your price of submission
or you could be you could be in the
european zone or the north american zone
and it will cost you a hell of a lot
more so gentlemen look wider afield
as far as social media is concerned uh
banksy style live you can get me on
actually star live and also speakers
corner online you can find me on there
um and um that's it just
check me out
um final thoughts i would say you know
what is king know yourself in it know
yourself know your worth at the end of
the day
she will pick you if you're the right
one and when you're the right one and
you're right together everything else
will work out fine so all these other
issues that everybody keeps talking
about they won't be yours king so love
yourself first make your money find your
wife
amen cheers
okay guys um a couple things before we
end the stream we have eclipse channel
guys go subscribe to the clips channel i
think we want to get 5k subs by the end
of the week so go subscribe the link is
in the description on top of that if you
want to come on the show message eddie
um the
you can find him he's in my instagram
description but his instagram is also in
the description of this video sign up
for our memberships we have a new tier
where you can have a one-on-one call
with me once a month so if you want to
join that we have a fourth tier as well
follow my instagram just dot pearly
things subscribe to the channel sign up
for memberships and we will talk to you
next time
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thank you so much
[Music]
you